WELL GOOD MORNING A WELCOME TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT.
TODAY WE HAVE A SPECIAL HEARING.
I'M FOCUS ON DIVERSITY AND TECH
AND HOW DO WE INCREASE.
DIVERSITY IN TECH HOW DO WE.
ARE CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR. AND
THOSE WHO DID HISTORICALLY.
DISADVANTAGE TO HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE A PART OF
INNOVATION.
I HAVE THE CHANCE TO EARN DECENT
WAGES AND TO CONTRIBUTE ARE TO
THE THINGS THAT.
THE TECHNOLOGY SECTOR HAS
PROVIDED FOR US.
ARE THIS HEARING LARGELY GROWS
OUT OF CONVERSATIONS THAT HAVE
TAKEN PLACE.
OF ACROSS A NUMBER OF CAUCUSES
HERE INCLUDING. A LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS.
TO EXPRESS CONCERNS ABOUT THE
NEED TO DO MORE TO DIVERSIFY THE
SECTOR.
ABOUT FORTY HERE FROM MY
COLLEAGUE.
CHAIR OF THE BLACK CAUCUS IN
JUST A MOMENT WHO HAVE SOME
REMARKS.
IF HE WOULD LIKE TO SHARE AND WE
THANK HIM FOR HIS LEADERSHIP. ON
THE SUBJECT OF. THEIR BEEN
INVITATIONS TO EVERY CAUCUS
AND EVERY ETHNIC CAUCUS
AND EVERY CAUCUS OF CONCERN TO
BE A PART.
TODAY'S CONVERSATION.
WE'VE ASKED EVERYONE.
I THINK ABOUT.
ONE KEY THING.
WHAT ARE SOLUTIONS?
TODAY'S MEETING IS NOT ABOUT
BLAME BUT WE ARE GONNA HAVE HARD
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT ARE THE
FACTS.
WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT WE
NEED TO DO TO MAKE CHANGES.
AND TO INCREASE DIVERSITY AND
TECH.
I'LL IN THAT RESPECT.
I'VE ALSO CONVENE A WORKING
GROUP THAT IS FOCUSED ON
CREATING.
STRATEGIES AND RECOMMENDATIONS
TO.
INCREASED DIVERSITY IN TECH
OF THE WORKING GROUP IS MADE UP
OF.
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES IT OUT AND
I'M VERY THANKFUL THIS BUT AT
LEAST A DOZEN.
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES IN LEADERS
HAVE ALREADY STEPPED UP.
EDUCATIONAL PARTNERS.
BOTH IN THE HIGHER EDUCATION
SECTOR AND INDICATE TWELVE
SECTOR.
GOVERNMENT LEADERS OTHER
EDUCATION LEADERS AND ADVOCATES
ALL WHO ARE FOCUSED ON.
WHAT WILL IT TAKE TO INCREASE OF
OUR REPRESENTATION IN TECHNOLOGY
AND SO IS OUR AND WE'LL TALK
MORE ABOUT THE WORKING GROUP AS
THIS HEARING TAKES PLACE TODAY?
A BUT I WANT TO LAY OUT A
FRAMEWORK OF WHERE WE HOPE TO
GO.
AND WE HOPE TO HAPPEN TODAY
TODAY'S A BUSY DAY IN THE
CAPITAL MANY MANY HEARINGS AND
SO MEMBERS WILL BE COMING IN AND
OUT. ARE AS THEY ARE ABLE TO.
BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
FRUITFUL CONVERSATION WE HAVE
SOME GREAT PANELS FOR YOU AND
THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO GET
UNDER WAY WITH THAT SAID. I
WELCOME AND I LIKE TURN IT OVER
TO.
CHAIR OF THE COSTLY LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHRIS HOLDEN.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN.
THIS IS CERTAINLY A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO.
BRING SOME ADDITIONAL FOCUS TO
AN AREA THAT HAS BEEN. A ONE
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE BEEN
WORKING ON IT LIKE TO THINK A
TECHNO AND.
OF THEIR.
MEMBER COMPANIES FOR OF BEING A
PART OF THE CONVERSATION THE
DIALOGUE OVER THE LAST YEAR
PLUS.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND I'D LIKE
TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
YOUR LATER LEADERSHIP. AND THE
ABILITY TO HAVE THIS DISCUSSION
UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF LABOR.
IT'S VERY FITTING.
YOU.
WORKING GROUP A TO HELP BRNG
ADDITIONAL FOCUS TO THE ISSUE I
THINK IS RIGHT ON TIME OF THE
BLACK CAUCUS HAS BEEN VERY
INTERESTED IN THIS ISSUE AND.
HAS.
A GOOD ADDRESSING IT AND TRYING
TO WORK MOVE THE BALL DOWN THE
FIELD IF YOU WILL. OFFER THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS AND SO. I LET
ME JUST TO SAY THAT AS THE
CHAIR.
OF THE CBC.
I'D LIKE TO.
AGAIN THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
BEING HERE BECAUSE THIS CREATES
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE DIALOGUE
TO CONTINUE AS THE CHAIRMAN HAS
SAID. OF FOR US TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT THE
ADVANCES
AND TECHNOLOGY.
THE PROGRESS EVERY ASPECT OF OUR
SOCIETY.
SPURS ACHIEVEMENT. AND ALL OTHER
INDUSTRIES INCLUDING HEALTHCARE
EDUCATION AND EVEN GOVERNMENT.
THEREFORE DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION IN THE TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY IS IMPERATIVE. FOR
THESE CONCEPTS TO PERMEATE
THROUGHOUT OUR SOCIETY AS THE
TECH INDUSTRY LEADS THE WAY.
AND SETS THE COURSE FOR THE REST
OF THE WORLD TO FOLLOW.
ESPECIALLY AS WE LOOK AT
CALIFORNIA IT IS VERY CLEAR THAT
HOW GOES CALIFORNIA SO GOES THE
NATION.
AS INDUSTRY GROWS WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THE FUTURE OF OUR
COMMUNITY ALSO AUTHORIZES OUR
WORLD BECOMES MORE
TECHNOLOGICALLY ADVANCED.
HOWEVER IN ORDER TO DO THAT WE
NEED EVERYONE'S HELP INCLUDING
THE TOP TECH COMPANIES
SPECIFICALLY THOSE IN
LEADERSHIP.
TRUE INITIATIVES FOR MORE
INCLUSIVE WORKFORCE REQUIRES
EXECUTIVE BOARD OF THESE
COMPANIES AND MAKE DIVERSITY A
TOP PRIORITY.
THIS IS WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY TO
LEARN WHAT PRACTICES AND
PROGRAMS ARE EMPLOYED AT THESE
COMPANIES.
TO ADVANCE OUR SOCIETY
SPECIFICALLY THOSE WHO ARE UNDER
REPRESENTED.
AND THE SAN FRANCISCO GATE.
NEWS ARTICLE IT IS STATED AND WE
DO HAVE THAT I DON'T KNOW ALL OF
YOU HAVE HAD A CHANCE TO SEE IT
BUT WE HAVE IN THE BACK SO YOU
HAVE A CHANCE TO LOOK AT THAT.
ARTICLE.
IT IS STATUS DISCRIMINATION HIS
THE OVER ARCHING BECAUSE OF
DISPROPORTIONATE RATES
REPRESENTATION AND HIGH PAIN
FEELS.
GAINES ARE ELUSIVE FOR MYRIAD OF
REASONS.
SUBSTANDARD SCHOOLS IN LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS
WHITE DOMINATED OFFICE CLICKS
BOARD ROOMS THEY PREFER
FAMILIARITY TO DIVERSITY.
DISCRIMINATORY HIRING PRACTICES
COMPANIES THAT CLAIM A LACK OF
QUALIFIED CANDIDATES BUT HAVE NO
PROBLEMS.
TRAIN MINORITY TALENT.
QUESTIONS I WOULD HOPE.
TO HAVE ANSWERS TO HERE TODAY
INCLUDE.
WHAT DOES THE OUT REACH CONSISTS
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS DO NOT
ATTEND HISTORICALLY BLACK
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES?
WE'VE HEARD THAT THERE IS OUT
REACH TO HISTORICALLY BLACK
COLLEGES AND WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
BEYOND THE.
HISTORICALLY BLACK COLLEGES
WHAT IS THE OUTREACH.
WHAT TYPE OF INCLUSIVE AREA
INCLUSIONARY PRACTICES YOU USE
IN THE HIRING PROCESS?
WORD RETENTION PROGRAMS AND
ADVANCEMENT IN TACK ARE READILY
AVAILABLE FOR THOSE AT YOUR
INSTITUTIONS.
HOW DO YOU PLAN TO DIVERSIFY
CORPORATE BOARDS WHEN THOSE WHO
ARE APPOINTED SERVE ON MULTIPLE
BOARDS LIMITING THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR FRESH FACES IN THE BOARD
ROOM?
WHAT ARE THE QUALIFICATIONS OR
THE GENERAL PROFILE OF THOSE
ELECTED TO SERVE ON YOUR BOARD
OF DIRECTORS AND HOW DOES YOUR
COMPANY DEMONSTRATE DIVERSITY AT
THE TOP?
THERE IS MUCH TALK ABOUT
PIPELINE CREATION BUT HOW HAS
YOUR COMPANY INVESTED IN THE
PIPELINE FROM OUR COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS. TO THE TECH WORLD.
SPECIFICALLY SIXTY PERCENT OF
THE NATION'S STUDENTS WHO BEGAN
HIGH SCHOOL INTERESTED IN STEM
LOSE INTEREST BEFORE GRADUATION
WITH LACK OF DIVERSE EXPOSURE
OPPORTUNITIES AMONG THE TOP
CAUSES.
WHERE MOST OF YOUR PROGRAMS
GEARED TOWARDS MIDDLE SCHOOLERS?
I UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
HIRING THE MOST QUALIFIED
INDIVIDUAL FOR JOBS.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY THERE
ARE MANY QUALIFIED PERSONS TO
FILL THESE TECHNICAL ROLES YET
THERE ARE A LARGE DISCREPANCIES
IN THEM BEING HIRED.
I APPRECIATE EACH OF YOU BEING
HERE TODAY TO SHARE WITH US SOME
OF YOUR PRACTICES AND PROPOSALS
FOR HOW WE CAN MOVE FORWARD. AND
DIVERSIFY THE TECH INDUSTRY.
THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN HOLDEN AND TO
YOUR POINTS TODAY.
WE WILL HEAR FROM.
THREE CEOS OF COMPANIES.
AS WELL AS FROM SOME VERY HIGH
LEVEL COMPANY REPRESENTATIVES.
AS I MENTION OUR WORK GROUP
WILL BE FOCUS ON.
A MATCHING APPLICANTS WITH JOBS
AS WELL AS HOW DO YOU USE THE
PIPELINE OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
PREPARED.
A FOR THE FUTURE OF WORK FOR
TECHNOLOGY OPPORTUNITIES IN THE
FUTURE.
OUT WE'RE HONORED.
TO BE JOINED BY A COLLEAGUE
FROM SENATE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LATINO CAUCUS AND HE
HAS BEEN. ALSO A LEADER IN THE
SUBJECT OF HOW WE INCREASE.
DIVERSITY AND TACK ON WOULD
WELCOME SENATOR HUESO IF HE
WISHES TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS HERE
BUT THIS IS A STORE WE DON'T GET
SENATORS IN THE ASSEMBLY SO.
WELL THAT'S WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT
MAKING HISTORY RIGHT AS
COME HERE MAKE HISTORY PUTS OUT
MORE MORE IMPORTANTLY JUST TO
THANK YOU FOR HOSTING.
THIS ARE VERY IMPORTANT.
A COMMITTEE A HEARING.
AND FORGET INPUT FROM.
MEMBERS OF OUR PARTICULATE AIR
WANT TO THANK THEM FOR BEING
HERE.
AND AND BE AN ACCESSIBLE AND BIG
BEEN WILLING TO DO THIS.
THERE THERE.
THERE HAS BEEN.
SEE CRITICISM OF NOT ONLY OF
THAT INDUSTRY BUT OF.
OTHERS ACROSS THE STATE.
AND WE WE DID.
RESOLUTION YESTERDAY AND SENATE.
.
CELEBRATING A STEM BUT ALSO
TALKING ABOUT INCREASING
DIVERSITY.
IN A IN.
.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT THE HIGH TECH
FIELDS.
IT WE HAVE WE HAVE SOME
CHALLENGES IN OUR STATE.
WE ALL UNDERSTAND THAT AND THAT
THE NUMBERS ARE VERY LOW.
FOR LATINO AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMEN.
HOW OLD THE MINORITY GROUPS
ALTHOUGH CHALLENGE GROUPS?
ARE HAVING A HARD TIME GETTING
ACCESS TO OF THESE INDUSTRIES.
THERE ARE SOME WONDERFUL
PROGRAMS OUT THERE THAT WE CAN
DEFINITELY.
CELEBRATE BUT A LOT MORE NEEDS
TO BE DONE.
YOUNG PEOPLE EMULATE THE ROLE
MODELS.
AND IF YOU COME FROM A LOW
INCOME COMMUNITY AND YOU DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO A.
OF A ROLE MODEL THAT IS.
IN THE HIGH TECH FIELD OR IS A
DOCTOR OR A BANK OR COMES FROM
A.
OF. OF A VERY EDUCATED FIELD.
YOU'RE YOUR YOUR ROLE MODEL
SEARCH SEVERELY LIMITED
ELIMINATE LIMITED.
AND THAT.
ALL HAS A LIMITING AFFECTING
YOUR POTENTIAL BECAUSE IN YOUR
MIND.
IT AFFECTS YOUR YOUR YOUR STATE
OF OF OF.
AWARENESS AND YOUR STATE OF MIND
AND YOUR CONFIDENCE SO THESE ARE
THINGS THAT.
THERE THERE ARE SOME WONDERFUL
PROGRAMS GROW PROGRAMS OUT THERE
THEY'RE GETTING KIDS INTO THE
WORK TECH ENVIRONMENT.
AND AND INTERNSHIP MAKING
INTERNSHIPS AVAILABLE BUT WE.
WE REALLY NEED TO.
DIVERSIFY IMPORTANT AREAS OF OF
OUR ECONOMY BECAUSE THEY WILL
ONLY MAKE THEM MORE PRODUCTIVE
AND THAT'S AN IMPORTANT.
AND WERE THE GOAL THAT THAT
THIS-LEGISLATURE SHOULD FOLK
FOCUS ON.
AND SO I WONDER WHAT REALLY ONE
THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS AND AND
GIVEN US THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
THIS INFORMATION BUT ALSO. MAKE
IT AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC AND
LET THEM KNOW THAT.
.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT AREA THAT
DESERVES OUR ATTENTION AND
EVERYBODY SHOULD HAVE.
THE ABILITY TO SPIRE TO ANYTHING
THEY WANTED TO IN THE STATE WE
SHOULD.
MAKE THOSE FIELDS.
AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE THAT THEY
WANT TO ENTER THEM.
AS MUCH AS WE CAN IT'S SAD. OF
THAT WE'VE HAD.
YEARS OF LEGISLATION PRIOR TO US
GETTING HERE PROP TWO ONE NINE.
AND OTHER DISCRIMINATORY
POLICIES THAT REALLY CAUGHT THE
PATHWAY TO CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS.
OBTAINING.
ADMISSION TO OUR UNIVERSITIES
AND.
A OBTAINING OUR. YOU KNOW
GOVERNMENT CONTRACTS IN THE JUST
SO MANY THINGS THAT WERE DONE
THAT WE.
WE NEED TO WORK TO TO UNDO.
MAN AND SOMETIMES IT'S EASIER
SAID THAN DONE GIVEN THE
CHALLENGES OF ADDING THOSE.
IT WAS BUILT THOSE LAWS TO THE
CONSTITUTION THE WAY THEY'VE
BEEN DONE.
THROUGH VOTER APPROVAL.
AND WE GOT IT WE BETTER FIND
WAYS.
CHU CHU.
MAKE THE STATE MARKS US WILL TO
ALL THE PEOPLE.
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR IMPORTANT
WORK THANK YOU CHAIRMAN HUESO
FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TENURE
LEADERSHIP.
I'M ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE MY
COLLEAGUE WHO IS A MEMBER OF
THIS COMMITTEE HAS BEEN A
CHAMPION ON A NUMBER OF ISSUES
OF SOCIAL JUSTICE AND REALLY
CREATING OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE
THAT HE'S BEEN COMMITTED. TO THE
SUBJECT OF DIVERSITY IN TECH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALLED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. OF FOR
HOLDING THIS IMPORTANT HEARING.
CENTER.
FOR YOUR COMMENTS FOR BEING
HERE WITH US.
AND YOU KNOW REPRESENTS HOUSING
CAPITAL SILICON VALLEY IS NO
DOUBT THAT.
NOTE WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO DO
WE CAN TO ENCOURAGE AND SUPPORT
OUR TECH SECTOR. NOT JUST
SILICON VALLEY BUT IN THE STATE
OF I THINK THERE BE ARE. THE
LEADERS IN TERMS OF THE
INNOVATION ECONOMY AND AND WE
SHOULD BE PROUD OF THAT.
I ALSO REPRESENT.
THE POOREST CENSUS TRACKS AND
SLOGAN VALLEY IN SAN JOSE AND
THE SAN JOSE. A WORK KIDS LIVING
IN THE SHADOWS OF SOME OF THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL ABOUT HIS
COMPANIES IN THE FACE OF THE
EARTH. A COULD NEVER EVEN
IMAGINE WALKING THROUGH THOSE
DOORS.
AND I KNOW.
THAT AS SENATOR HUESO INDICATE
IT'S NOT JUST TACK IT YOU KNOW
THESE ISSUES PROCESSED IN SO
MANY DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES. BUT I
THINK TECH.
HOLD A SOFT A HIGHER STANDARD
I AM NOT THAT'S A GOOD THING
THAT THEY DO.
THE QUESTION IS HOW DO WE MOVE
FORWARD HOW DO WE GET TO A PLACE
WHERE. WE CAN START TO REALLY
MAKE SIGNIFICANT. OVEN APPROVED
AND ROADS IN TERMS OF ENSURING
THAT WE'RE GETTING MORE
DIVERSITY MORE INCLUSION I THINK
SOUTHERN BEEN SOME SUCCESSFUL
I'M SURE WE'LL HEAR FROM SOME OF
THAT PROGRAMS BUT. I AS A
SANDERS SAID OF THIS
CONVERSATION'S BEEN HAPPENING
FOR FAR TOO LONG WITHOUT. THE
REAL IMPACTS I THINK THAT WE
CERTAINLY DID LIKE I'VE TO SEE
HAPPEN.
IF YOU GO TO ESE SALAS A SITE
UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT YOU
HAVE YOUR PIPELINE RIGHT THERE.
AND THE PIPELINE IS READY TO BE
THE NEXT GENERATION OF ENGINEERS
OF.
OF MARKETING EXPERTS I'VE YOU
NAME IT.
THEY'RE THERE AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE THEY'RE TOO EAGER TO
LEARN AND SO I DIE AND YOU CAN
REPLICATE THAT SAME THING
WHETHER IT'S IN LA SAN DIEGO
THROUGHOUT THE CITY CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE THE TALENT BASE IN OUR
SCHOOLS. HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT
THEY HAD THAT OPPORTUNITY
PARTICULARLY PEOPLE COLOR WOMEN
UP FOR THOSE REALLY OF OF?
INNOVATIVE AND A WELL PAYING
AND.
REALLY THOUGHT PROVOKING ATTACK
JOBS SUB THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING.
THANK YOU SO INNER KALRA AND FOR
POINTING TO YOUR DISTRICT FOR
PROVIDING THE PIPELINE OF THE
FUTURE AND INACTION.
YEAH WILL FOLLOW YOUR LEAD WILL
FOLLOW YOUR LEAD YOU'RE RIGHT
THIS IS.
WE KNOW HOW WE KNOW HOW TO
INNOVATE WE KNOW HOW TO.
AND HELP THOSE WHO WANT TO ENTER
THE PROFESSION
TO GET THE SUPPORT THAT THEY
NEED TO GET THERE AND IT'S UPON
US. TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN
AND I SHOULD SAY THAT THIS IS A
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE TECH
SECTOR. AND GOVERNMENT AND
ADVOCATES WORKING TOGETHER AND
SO WE THANK.
TECHNET PARTNERS AND THOSE WHO
COME HERE TODAY ASSEMBLED ON
SHORT NOTICE TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
WE GONNA DO ABOUT IT. SO HAVING
SAID THAT LET'S JUST GET TO IT.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN TALK ALL DAY
BUT IT'S TIME FOR ACTION.
I'M EXCITED TO BRING FORWARD OUR
OUR FIRST PANELIST.
TO HELP US FRAME THE ISSUE.
.
REPRESENTING.
WOMEN ATTACK.
AND THE CLAIM INSTITUTE
AT STANFORD A DOCTOR JOANNE
WEHNER.
AND TO TALK ABOUT UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITIES INTACT.
MICHELLE FLOWERS TAYLOR FROM USC
WOULD WELCOME YOU TO COME TO
OUR.
PANELISTS TABLE.
.
AND YOU KNOW.
I KNOW THEY TOLD YOU TO TALK FOR
A LONG TIME YOU KNOW THE WAY WE
TRY TO DO THESE IS REALLY JUST
TWO TO THREE MINUTES OF REALLY
HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW OF KEYS.
POINT SO THAT WE LEAVE TIED FOR
THE QUESTIONS AND MAKE THAT THE
THAT. THE HEART OF THE TIME.
YOU KNOW I THINK OUR MISSION
TODAY AS WE TALK ABOUT WHAT'S
WORKING LET'S BE STRAIGHT BASE.
ARM WHAT ARE THE BARRIERS AND
HOW TO GET PAST THEM.
AND THEN WHAT ARE THE SOLUTIONS
THAT WE NEED TO CARRY OUT AND
SO.
WE LOOK FOR WHAT YOU HAVE
PREPARED FOR US.
AND.
WELCOME YOU WHEN YOU ARE READY.
DOT WHEN.
THANK YOU CHAIRING COMMITTEE FOR
GIVING ME THE CHANCE TO
TODAY AND JOB PRESENT SOME OF
THE RESEARCH WE'RE DOING AT THE
CLAIM INSTITUTE. AT STANFORD ON
WOMEN IN TACK.
I.
MY NAME IS A
EVEN IF THE STATE WAS ABLE TO
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF WOMEN. EARNING CS DEGREES IN
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE WOMEN
WAS HIRED IN SILICON VALLEY TECH
COMPANIES. TOMORROW IT WOULD NOT
SOLVE THE LARGER MORE DEEPLY
ENTRENCHED PROBLEM OF STRUCTURAL
INEQUALITY. THAT IS BUILT INTO
THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT SERVES TO
LIMIT WOMEN'S OPPORTUNITIES
WITHIN THESE COMPANIES. AS WELL
AS DRIVE THEM OUT OF THE FIELD
ALTOGETHER.
ABOUT TECHNICAL WOMEN AND.
THERE'S ALWAYS AN ASSUMPTION
THAT ONCE THESE WOMEN ARE HIRED
AT AND FEW LEVEL POSITIONS
THEY'RE GOING TOOF COURSE BE
HAPPY WORKING FOR TECH
COMPANIES.
THAT THEY'RE GONNA THRIVE THERE
WANT TO STAY AND THEY'LL BE
PROMOTED INTO LEADERSHIP AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN THAT THIS PROBLEM
WILL NO LONGER EXIST.
HOWEVER THIS ISN'T A SUCH A
FALSE ASSUMPTION THAT RESEARCH
JUSTICE NOT SUBSIDE PORT.
WEEBLY BELIEVE THAT IT'S
ACTUALLY THE BIASES THAT ARE BUT
BUILT BAKED INTO WORKPLACES AT
TECH COMPANIES THAT SERVE TO
AMPLIFY BIAS.
AND REINFORCE THE LACK OF WOMEN
IN TACT YEAR AFTER YEAR.
IN TWENTY SECOND SIXTEEN DATA
FOUND THAT WOMEN MAKE UP ABOUT
TWENTY SIX PERCENT OF ALL
COMPUTING OCCUPATIONS. AND THIS
IS A DROP FROM EARLY NINETIES
DATA THAT SHOWS THAT WOMEN WERE
ABOUT THIRTY SIX PERCENT SO
THERE'S A DROP IN WOMEN'S
REPRESENTATION INTACT. THAT'S
BEEN HAPPENING SINCE THE
NINETEEN NINETIES WHEREAS IT'S
BEEN AN INCREASE IN OTHER
FIELDS.
WHAT WE LOOK FOR SPECIFIC DATA
ON TACK
I IN THE SILICON VALLEY? THAT
THOSE NUMBERS ARE NOT REALLY
READILY AVAILABLE BECAUSE
THEY'RE GENERALLY VOLUNTARILY
GIVEN. BUT.
OR REQUIRED BY E. OC BUT
SPECIFIC COMPANIES SUCH AS
GOOGLE OR FACEBOOK MICROSOFT
TWITTER EXCEDRIN. OFTEN
VOLUNTARILY REPORT OF THEIR
GENDER AND OTHER DIVERSITY
METRICS AND WOMEN MAKE UP
ANYWHERE FROM TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT TO CLOSE TO FIFTY
PERCENT OF THEIR OVERALL WORK
FORCE.
YET THE ONLY HOLD BETWEEN
FIFTEEN PERCENT TO TWENTY SEVEN
PERCENT OF TECHNICAL ROLES.
WITHIN THESE COMPANIES AND WOMEN
HOLD BETWEEN EIGHTEEN PERCENT
AND THIRTY PERCENT OF LEADERSHIP
ROLE THAT THESE COMPANIES.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN RESEARCH BY
ANITA BORG A
IT'S THE THREE SILICON VALLEY
TECH COMPANIES FOUND THAT THE
BIGGEST AREA OF GROWTH FOR WOMEN
INTACT WITHOUT THE ENTRY LEVEL
SO IT WAS TWENTY TWO PERCENT AND
TWENTY FIFTEEN. AND THAT RISEN
TO TWENTY EIGHT POINT FIVE AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
SUGGESTING THE PIPELINE IS IN
FACT IMPROVING.
BUT AS IS OFTEN THE CASE WOMEN
CONTINUE TO BE UNDER REPRESENTED
AT THE SENIOR EXECUTIVE LEVELS.
CONSISTING OF NINETEEN PERCENT
AND FIFTEEN PERCENT RESPECTIVELY
AND THIS IS SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
THE BEST WAY FOR WOMEN TO
INFLUENCE THE CULTURE OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS. AND TECH MORE
BROADLY IS BY INCREASING THE
REPRESENTATION IN LEADERSHIP.
EVEN MORE SURPRISING IS THAT
WOMEN WORKING IN TECH COMPANIES
LEAVES AT TWICE THE RATE OF
THEIR MALE COLLEAGUES.
FORTY ONE PERCENT OF WOMEN WILL
LEAVE TECH AT MID CAREER
COMPARED TO ONLY SEVENTEEN
PERCENT OF MEN.
THE RATE OF FEMALE ATTRITION AND
TECH IS HIGHER THANOTHER STEM
FIELDS SO IT'S NOT SIMPLY
SOMETHING THAT ALL SCIENCES
SUFFER FROM BUT SOMETHING ABOUT
TECH IN PARTICULAR.
MANY QUALITATIVE STUDIES SUGGEST
THAT MANY WOMEN DON'T FEEL
WELCOME OR INCLUDED IN TACK
WE'VE HEARD FROM MALE MANAGERS
WHOSE ALL MAIL ME MALE
ENGINEERING TEAMS WILL SAY THEY
SPECIFICALLY DO NOT WANT TO HIRE
WOMEN ONTO THEIR TEAMS. AS THEY
SERVICE A BUZZ KILL OR AS ONE
WOMAN I HEARD FROM IN A FOCUS
GROUP STATED SHE COULD CARE LESS
ABOUT THE TRADITIONAL BENEFITS.
THAT ARE OFFERED AT TECH
COMPANIES SUCH AS GO CARTS ARE
PING PONG TABLES AND INSTEAD
WANTED TO KNOW ABOUT MATERNITY
LEAVE AND LACTATION ROOMS.
SO WHAT CAN BE DONE IN OUR WORK
WITH ACTUAL TECH COMPANIES WERE
TESTING A CHANGE MODEL THAT'S
FOCUSED ON A SMALL WINS
APPROACH.
THAT MEANS RATHER THAN
ENCOURAGING LARGE SCALE DENY
INITIATIVES WE RECOMMEND THAT
COMPANIES.
START OFF SMALL RUNNING TEAM
BASED INTERVENTIONS DESIGNED TO
DISRUPT THE BIASES THAT ARE
HURTING WOMEN AND OTHER UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITIES
LIKELIHOOD OF SUCCESS.
R. CHANGE MODEL IS FAIRLY SIMPLE
STARTING OFF TO WORK WITH TEAMS
OF MANAGERS TO CO DEVELOP TOOLS
DESIGNED TO REDUCE BIAS.
IN SPECIFIC EVALUATIVE PROCESS
HE'S SUCH AS HIRING PERFORMANCE
EVALUATIONS OUR TALENT ABUSING
CALIBRATIONS.
PLACES WHERE DIAL WOMEN AND
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITIES TEND
TO GET LOWER RATINGS AND THEN
THAT IN TURN HURTS THEIR CHANCES
OF MOVING UP THE LADDER. FIRST
MANAGERS NEED TO BE EGGED
EDUCATED ON STEREOTYPES AND
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS
SO THEY CAN RECOGNIZE BIAS AND
AVOID BUILDING IT INTO NEW TOOLS
AND PROPHECIES.
SECOND ORGANIZATIONS IN NEED TO
ANALYZE THEIR DIVERSE CITY DATA
MANY COMPANIES WE TALKED TO
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE WOMEN WERE
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS ARE
FALLING OUT OF THEIR PIPELINE.
THEY DON'T KNOW AT WHAT LEVEL
WOMEN ARE STE.
THE RIGHT HAVING SERIOUS
RETENTION PROBLEMS SO WE REALLY
TOUGH ONE OF THE FIRST STEPS OF
THE NEED TO KNOW WHERE WOMEN AND
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS.
ARE IN THEIR COMPANY WHERE
THEY'RE FALLING OUT AND WHAT
WHERE THEN THEY NEED TO MAKE
THEIR CONCERTED EFFORTS ON
DIVERSITY RATHER THAN TRYING TO
DO. A SHOTGUN APPROACH.
NEXT TO WORK OF MANAGERS TO
THEN DEVELOP A TOOL THAT CAN
SPEAK THE PROCESS WERE BIAS
APPEARS TO BE IMPACTING
OUTCOMES.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF THEY HAVE
UNCLEAR OR AMBIGUOUS CRITERIA
AROUND PERFORMANCE EVALUATION.
THAT IS LEADING TO MEN AND WOMEN
BEING EVALUATED DIFFERENTLY.
THAT.
THEY CAN WE CAN WORK WITH THEM
TO MAKE MUCH CLEARER CRITERIA
THAT IS BET METRIC BASED RATHER
THAN BASED ON.
PEOPLE'S OPINIONS OF INDIVIDUALS
OR THEIR PERCEPTIONS OF WHAT
THAT INDIVIDUAL IS CAPABLE OF
RATHER IT'S BASED ON HARD
NUMBERS OR METRICS OF
PERFORMANCE.
THEN THIS INTERVENTION OCT AND
TOOLS ARE STE DESIGNED TO SERVE
AS A MEASURABLE CHANGE THAT
MANAGERS CAN THEN SEE. AND BE
ENCOURAGED BY IN THE HOPES THAT
THEY'LL WANT TO DO MORE TO ROOT
OUT BIAS IN THE ORGANIZATION AND
CREATE BETTER PROPHECIES.
FINALLY WE MEASURE THE SUCCESS
OF THE CHANGE OR INTERVENTION
OFTEN SHOWING MEN AND WOMEN SAY
RECEIVING SIMILAR FEEDBACK OR
SHRINKING THE SIGNIFICANT GENDER
GAP IN PERFORMANCE RATINGS THAT
HAD PREVIOUSLY EXISTED. AND THIS
CAN GIVE MANAGERS A FEELING OF.
EXCITEMENT AND FEELING THAT
THEY CAN ACTUALLY PRODUCE CHANGE
UP THEIR COMPANY AND THEY MIGHT
THEN WE HOPE THAT THEY'LL THEN
IT TALK TO OTHER MANAGERS ABOUT
THAT. INTRODUCE IT TO OTHER
PROPHECIES AND THEN THAT WILL
LEAD TO.
A FEW CHANGES AT THE COMPANY
FROM THESE INDIVIDUALS SHARING
THEIR AYE.
IDEAS BECAUSE IT ALSO DOESN'T
RELY ON LEADERSHIP WHICH CHANGES
A LOT SO IF YOU JUST HAVE ONE
PERSON WHO'S COMMITTED TO THE
PROBLEM. IF THAT PERSON LEAVES
OFTENTIMES DIVERSITY FALLS TO
THE WAYSIDE.
IN OUR RECENT WORK WITH GO DADDY
WE WORKED WITH THEIR EXECUTIVE
LEADERS TO SIMPLIFY THEIR VALUES
AND CREATE A SCORECARD THAT
MANAGERS COULD USE WHEN MEETING
IN CALIBRATING EMPLOYEE
PERFORMANCE. RATINGS THAT AFFECT
PAY AND PROMOTION DECISIONS
DEVELOPING THE SCORECARD
REQUIRED CREATING MEASURABLE
CRITERIA FOR EVALUATING
EMPLOYEES THAT WERE ALIGNED WITH
THE COMPANY'S VALUES. AND COULD
BE APPLIED CONSISTENTLY ACROSS
EMPLOYEES
WE BELIEVE CONSISTENCY IS ONE OF
THE BIGGEST WAYS MANAGERS CAN
ENSURE THAT ALL EMPLOYEES
REGARDLESS OF GENDER RACE ARE
BEING EVALUATED AGAINST THE SAME
CRITERIA. AND THAT'S ACTUALLY
BEING IN THE MERITOCRACY THAT WE
ALL WANT TO HAVE HAPPEN WITHIN
TACK.
THE USE OF THE SCORECARD
PRODUCED IMMEDIATE REDUCTIONS IN
THE GENDER GAP PREVIOUSLY FOUND
IN PERFORMANCE RATINGS USED IN
PROMOTION DECISIONS AND THIS
TYPE OF A SMALL WHEN AS WE HAVE
SHOWN CAN MOTIVATE FURTHER
ACTIONS THAT LEAD TO LARGER
ORGANIZATIONAL TRANSFORMATION.
SUCH AS OTHER ORGANIZATIONS THAT
THE COMPANY ADOPTING SIMILAR
CRITERIA FOR THEIR EVALUATIONS.
AS WELL AS MAKING A CONCERTED
EFFORT TO HIGH MORE HIRE MORE
WOMEN AMONG THEIR NEW
ENGINEERING GRADUATE HIRES.
THERE WERE MANY NAY SAYERS IN
THE COMPANY AND LEADERS WHO
NEEDED TO BE BROUGHT ALONG BUT
IN THE END AS IS USUALLY THE
CASE. PARTICIPATING LEADERS
REPORTED FEELING THAT TAKING
THOSE EXTRA FEW MINUTES TO
CLARIFY CRITERIA. MADE THEM
BETTER MANAGERS MADE THEM BETTER
OF MORE MORE CONSCIOUS OF THE
FACT THAT THEY WERE EVALUATING
PEOPLE FAIRLY WHICH WAS THEIR
ULTIMATE GOAL AS A MANAGER IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
WE'RE PROUD TO SHOW THAT THROUGH
THOUGHTFUL AND MANAGEABLE CHANGE
ACCOMPANY LIKE GO DADDY WHO HAD
PREVIOUSLY BEEN BEEN KNOWN FOR
ITS SEXIST TELEVISION
COMMERCIALS. IS NOW INCLUDED ON
LISTS OF THE BEST COMPANIES FOR
WOMEN TO WORK FOR.
THEREFORE AS AN INSTITUTE WE
BELIEVE THAT CHANGE IS POSSIBLE
BUT THE FOCUS NEEDS TO BE ON
CREATING TRULY MERITOCRATIC
STRUCTURES WERE ALL PEOPLE
REGARDLESS OF GENDER. TRULY HAVE
AN EQUAL CHANCE OF SUCCESS
IT'S ONLY BY REDUCING THE
AFFECTS OF BIAS IN THE
STRUCTURES THAT TRUE CHANGE AND
DIVERSITY IN TECH WILL OCCUR.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WINNER.
WOULD LIKE TO NOT HEAR FROM MS
FLOWERS TAYLOR.
HELLO GOOD MORNING.
YES MY NAME IS DOCTOR MICHELLE
FLOWERS TAYLOR.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO FIRST LIKE
TO THANK THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR HOLDING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT HEARING IT SO TIMELY
AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT AND I'M
GLAD THAT YOU GUYS ARE ALL ON
BOARDING COMMITTED TO REALLY
MAKE AN IMPACT IN OUR BEAUTIFUL
STATE.
AYE CURRENTLY AND THE DIRECTOR
OF AN INSTITUTE CALLED THE
INSTITUTE OF ENGINEERING.
COMMUNITY AND CULTURAL
COMPETENCE WHICH IS BASED AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. IN THE VITERBI
SCHOOL OF ENGINEERING.
AND THE WORK THAT I DO THERE WAS
BORN OUT OF MY RESEARCH ON.
ACADEMICALLY HIGH ACHIEVING
AFRICAN AMERICAN FEMALE
STUDENTS.
BECAUSE OTHER SO MUCH RESEARCH
ON WHAT'S NOT WORKING.
WITHOUT POPULATION.
BUT THERE IS SO MUCH THAT IS IN
FACT WORKING AND SO I'VE NOW
PARTLY MY RESEARCH TO WORKING IN
THE ENGINEERING SCHOOL. TO
PROVIDE OUTREACH TO MIDDLE
SCHOOL GIRLS WHO ARE AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND LATINA. FROM
UNDERSERVED LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND SOME HERE TO TALK TO YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
.
SOME OF MY RESEARCH FINDINGS AND
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT I'VE.
A SCENE WORKING SINCE WE WANTED
USE AND HOT ASSET BASED
APPROACH.
FOR THIS CONVERSATION.
INSIDE LIKE TO.
HIGHLIGHT ONE ISSUE THAT IS OF
CONCERN.
AS MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED AND AS
OTHER FOLKS HERE MENTIONED. A
GROCER JUST AS.
CAPABLE IN GIRLS AND WOMEN ARE
JUST AS CAPABLE AND IN FACT
MIDDLE SCHOOL GIRLS ARE JUST AS
INTERESTED IN STEM AS BOYS ARE.
BUT THERE TENDS TO BE A DROP OFF
EIGHTH GRADE NINTH GRADE WHERE
THEY JUST.
GO FROM LIKING MATH LIKING
SCIENCE LIKING TECHNOLOGY AND
THEY LOSE ALL INTEREST.
SO I HAVE SOME.
PRESENTATION HERE TO SHARE WITH
YOU.
THERE ARE REALLY IN MY RESEARCH
I FOUND THERE'S THREE REASONS
WHY. THERE'S THIS DROP OFF.
THE FIRST AND PERHAPS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT REASONS IS.
THE GIRLS FEEL AND EXPRESS
A LACK OF.
CONNECTION A LACK OF RELEVANCE
TO THEIR DAILY LIVES.
SURE THEY ALL HAVE IPHONES BUT
THEY DON'T THEY MAY NOT SEE THE
VALUE. OF HAVING THAT KNOWLEDGE
THAT NOT ONLY CAN YOU BE A
CONSUMER OF THAT IPHONE YOU CAN
ALSO BE A PRODUCER TECHNOLOGY
JUST LIKE THAT I.
SO THAT'S A THAT'S A REAL ISSUE
A LACK OF RELEVANCE.
SECONDLY.
IN THE RESEARCH IT STATES THAT.
THERE'S A. THERE'S A REAL ISSUE
AROUND GIRLS HAVING WHAT'S
CALLED A FIXED MINDSET.
WHERE THEY SAY I'M JUST NOT GOOD
AT THAT I'M NOT GOOD AT MATH?
AND A LOT OF THOSE FIX MINDSET
CHARACTERISTICS ARE. DETERMINED
BY STEREOTYPES
AND GROWTH SUCCUMBING. TO THOSE
STEREOTYPES
GIRLS AND GIRLS OF COLOR IN
PARTICULAR.
ARE.
ARE SUSCEPTIBLE
TO THE THAT MINDSET WHICH REALLY
IS.
SCOURGING AND CAN DISTRACT THEM
FROM EVEN HAVING THAT.
A.
POSSIBLE SELF OR VIEW ABOUT
POSSIBLE SELF AS BEING A
TECHNOLOGIST SO THAT SECOND.
AND THAT'S
SOMETIMES SUPPORTED
UNFORTUNATELY BY THEIR SCHOOL AN
ACADEMIC SETTING.
OKAY.
AND THIRD THERE'S A LACK OF
ACCESS TO HANDS ON OPPORTUNITIES
TO EXPLORE. AND MAKE MISTAKES
TINKER BUILD AGAIN.
SO.
AND AS MY.
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN IN AS A
RESEARCH OF MANY OTHER RESEARCH
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE AND OTHERS
HAVE SHOWN. I'M THERE'S WAYS TO
WORK COLLABORATIVELY.
TO BREAK DOWN SOME OF THESE
CHALLENGES.
AND ONE MODEL I WANNA HIGHLIGHT
IS.
PRODUCT OF MY RESEARCH.
IT'S REALLY ABOUT BRINGING
CONCEPTS TOGETHER THAT EXIST
CURRENTLY IN THE AND THE
RESEARCH BUT BRING IT TOGETHER
FOR THE PURPOSE OF CREATING
FEMALE STEM ENTREPRENEURS OF THE
FUTURE.
BASED ON NUMBER ONE ENCOURAGING
IN FEMALE STUDENTS OF COLOR.
AND AFFIRMS.
FUND OF KNOWLEDGE.
WHAT THAT MEANS IT COMES FROM
ANTHROPOLOGY?
BUT THE TERM MEANS.
HELPING STUDENTS AFFIRM THEIR
SOCIO CULTURAL THEIR LINGUISTIC
BACKGROUNDS.
WHAT THEY KNOW PLACING THEM IN
THE ROLE OF EXPERTS?
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES TO
STEM.
BECAUSE THAT'S ONE VERY CLEAR
WAY TO HELP THEM SEE THE
RELEVANCE.
OF STEM
THE DIRECT RELEVANCE TO THEIR
LIVES.
AND SECONDLY INCREASING THEIR
GROWTH MINDSET.
SO THAT THEY CAN SEE I MAY NOT
BE GOOD AT MATH RIGHT NOW.
BUT HONESTLY WHOEVER WAS IN THE
BEGINNING LIKE NO AND RIGHT.
EVEN MATHEMATICIANS YOU NO I
WORKING AT USC AND I MEET REALLY
SMART FOLKS.
AND THEY ARE LEADING INITIATIVES
JUST LIKE MYSELF.
IN MATH AND ENGINEERING IT'S
ULTRA AND THEY DIDN'T GET IT
RIGHT THE FIRST TIME SO IT'S
REALLY ABOUT STRESSING THE VALUE
A FAILURE. IN THE VALUE OF
MAKING MISTAKES AND IT'S OKAY.
AND THEN THIRD GIVING THEM HANDS
ON OPPORTUNITIES TO TRY AND
EXPLORE.
BUT FIRST TO DO THIS WE HAVE TO
MOVE FROM THEORY TO PRACTICE.
AND WITHOUT IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO.
ADDRESS THE NEEDS NOT ONLY OF
THE CHILD'S BUT ALSO THE
COMMUNITY IN WHICH THEY FIND
THEMSELVES.
AND THE FAMILY STRUCTURE.
SO BY GIVING CONTENT PROVIDING
CONTENT TO.
THE YOUNG GIRLS THEMSELVES BUT
ALSO ENGAGING THEIR PARENTS IN
THAT PROCESS.
TO CREATE A STEM FAMILY.
SO IT'S COMPLETELY NORMAL.
WE ALL SEE PARENTS GOING TO
BASEBALL GAMES
SOCCER GAMES.
YOU KNOW WHY COULDN'T WE SEE
MORE PARENTS SUPPORTING THESE
ENGINEERING. CHAMPIONSHIPS YOU
KNOW THESE MATH OLYMPICS JUST AT
THE SAME LEVEL RIGHT.
I AND SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
GIVE YOU. A LITTLE.
ANECDOTAL. EXAMPLE.
SO BRING THESE CONCEPTS TOGETHER
THE FUNDS OF KNOWLEDGE GROWTH
MINDSET IN HANDS ON LEARNING.
TO PROVIDE CONTENT FOR MIDDLE
SCHOOL GIRLS OF COLOR.
A LAST SUMMER. I HAD A GREAT
SUCCESS I'D LIKE TO SHARE WITH
YOU.
THEIR ELEVEN YEAR OLD GIRLS AND
EACH SUMMER WE WORK ON A
NATIONAL ACADEMY OF ENGINEERING
GRAND CHALLENGE.
SO LAST YEAR'S CHALLENGE WAS
IMPROVE URBAN INFRASTRUCTURE
WHETHER ELEVEN SO YOU HAVE TO
SAY IT LIKE THEY CAN UNDERSTAND
IT SO. WE SAY IMPROVE YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
SO FIRST STEP WAS PLACING THEM.
IN THE ROLE OF EXPERTS
BUILDING ON THE FUNDS OF
KNOWLEDGE ASKING THOSE GIRLS
WHAT IS IN YOUR COMMUNITY YOU
WANT TO SEE DIFFERENT WHAT DO
YOU WANT TO SEE CHANGE.
SECONDLY GIVING THEM THE HANDS
ON TOOLS SO IN THIS CASE IT WAS
OUT DEVELOPMENT.
AND THEN GIVING THEM GROWTH
MINDSET TRAINING SO THEY CONCEDE
THAT THROUGH EFFORT AND YOUR
MISTAKE YOU CAN ACTUALLY GET
BETTER.
WELL THE WINNING TEAM THE
OUTCOME THERE ELEVEN YEARS OLD.
AND THESE GIRLS MADE AN ANTI
HUMAN TRAFFICKING UP.
THAT WORKED AT A GEO LOCATION
IT'S READY TO GO ON THE APP
STORE.
IT'S READY FOR
COMMERCIALIZATION.
AND THAT'S THE PRODUCT OF
PLACING GIRLS AND THE ROLE OF
EXPERTS.
IN THEIR WORLDS.
AND THEN THE TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGY ARE NO LONGER A
HINDRANCE
THERE ARE TWO THEY'RE JUST THAT
WHAT THEY SHOULD BE ENOUGH TO
TOOL.
TO HELP IMPROVE THEIR LIVES.
THEY'RE YOUNG GIRLS BUT THEY
HAVE LOTS TO SAY AND SO. THIS IS
ONE WAY I BELIEVE TO REALLY.
HELP UNDERSERVED GIRLS AND
UNDERREPRESENTED POPULATIONS.
FIND THEIR WAY IN TECHNOLOGY AND
ENGAGE THEM.
SO.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO SAY
THERE'S ROOM TO SCARE ALL.
THERE'S ROOM TO COLLABORATE.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY THIS IS
SO SO VERY CRITICAL THAT WE'RE
ALL HERE TALKING.
NOT JUST ACADEMICS BUT.
POLICY LEADERS.
LEADERS IN THE K. TWELVE SPACE.
AS WELL AS TECH LEADERS WHO ARE
GOING TO SPEAK.
BECAUSE BY WORKING TOGETHER. AND
BUILDING ON THE FUNDS OF
KNOWLEDGE OF OUR POPULATIONS.
AN INCREASING A AND OUT TIGHT
FOR GROWTH MIND SADDENED WITH
TRIAL YOU CAN ACTUALLY BE A PART
OF THIS GAME AND STAY IN IT.
AND THEN GIVING PEOPLE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TOUCH THINGS AND
EXPLORE I THINK WE REALLY ARE ON
THE RIGHT PATH TO MAKING SOME
CRITICAL CHANGES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR FLOWERS TAYLOR VERY
MUCH OUT OF THEM TEND TO THE
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE IT'S IF
THERE ANY QUESTIONS.
SOME OF COLOR BUT JUST I WANT
THANK BOTH YOU A DOCTOR FLOWERS
TAYLOR. AND IN REGARDS TO.
AND THE FOR THE I. E. C. THREE
MODEL. AND THEN WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE DIFFERENT.
.
THINGS THAT ARE NEEDED.
IN NOTHING STIR IT YOU HIT ON A
LOT OF THEM NOTHING WE'VE HEARD.
THINK THE ON STEREOTYPES FOR
CERTAIN THAT IT DOESN'T LOT OF
SOCIETAL ISSUES STARTS EVEN IN
THE FAMILY OFTENTIMES.
RIGHT WITH THE BOYS AND GIRLS
ARE TREATED DIFFERENTLY IN TERMS
OF WHAT THEIR FUTURE PATH ISN'T
SO I APPRECIATE YOU. BRINGING
THAT UP AND AND TRIMS LOAD LIMIT
ACCESS TO HANDS ON STEM LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES I SEE IT YOU KNOW
YOU GO TO MIDDLE SCHOOLS.
AND AND YOU LOOK AT EITHER OF
THE EXTRA CURRICULAR ARE
VOLUNTARY ACTIVITIES. YOU'LL SEE
IF IT'S A SUCH A SCIENCE FAIR OR
A ROBOTICS COMPETITION IS PRETTY
MUCH EVEN SPLIT IN MIDDLE SCHOOL
AND THEN HIGH SCHOOL JUNIOR
SENIOR YEAR THE SAME. ACTIVITIES
AS ALMOST ALL BOYS RIGHT AND SO
I I I HAVE SEEN AND ADORED ME
I'D AND I'M SOME OVER MANY YEARS
YOU SEE THAT HAPPENING TIME AND
AGAIN.
MY QUESTION IS ON.
THERE'S A LOT A TECH CAMPS LARA
SCIENCE COUNTS NOW THAT A LOT OF
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE BEING ABOUT THE
PARENTS GOVERNMENT AND THE
REALLY EXPENSIVE.
AND SO. ALL AND SOME OF THEM
ARE FOCUSING ON WHAT NOT ON
GIRLS. AND YOUNG GIRLS AND AND
AND YOUNG LADIES AND WOMEN.
AT THEM BUT STILL ON THE ACCESS
IS IN THERE I LOVE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING HOW DO WE SKILLED THAT IN
PARTNERING WITH OUR TECH
COMMUNITY SO THAT EVERY. YOUNG
GIRL HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
YES THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION
AND.
I REALLY APPRECIATE.
THE FACT THAT YOU'RE ASKING
ABOUT THE.
MONETARY CONCERNS I MEAN THAT'S
A REAL HUGE ISSUE.
AND I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
BIGGEST.
AREAS AND. FOR COLLABORATION.
I'M HONESTLY I THINK
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT TECH LEADERS
WE TALK ABOUT ACADEMIA IN
PARTICULAR WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO THOSE KIDS.
AND SO WITH THAT RESPONSIBILITY
THERE'S A POTENTIAL FOR.
PROVIDING SOME SUPPORT.
RIGHT ARM WEEKEND GREATLY BY
PROVIDING THOSE KIDS WITH THIS
TRAINING.
SO WHY NOT INVEST IN THAT IT'S A
WORK FORCE IN DEVELOPMENT.
THIS IS NOT AND IT'S NOT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT IT IN THAT
CONTEXT IS NOT A SHORT TERM
GAIN.
IT'S A LONG TERM GAIN SO WE HAVE
TO INVEST IN THE LONG TERM AND I
THINK I SPEAKING AS A
UNIVERSITY.
YOU KNOW REPRESENTATIVE I THINK
THAT'S UNIVERSITY WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO CONTRIBUTE
ABOUT AND THAT COULD MEAN
SCHOLARSHIPS THAT COULD MEAN.
PROVIDING FOR CERTAIN FAMILIES
THAT COULD MEAN PROVIDING LOW IN
FREE RESOURCE OPPORTUNITIES AND
COLLABORATING WITH SCHOOLS AND
TECH LEADERS TO ACTUALLY.
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE ACCESS TO
FAMILIES THAT ORDINARILY WOULD
HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY AND I LIKE
THREE FOUR FRAMED AS WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR BOTH.
OF THE STATE AND GOVERNMENT AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
UNIVERSITIES AS WELL AS FOR THE
TECH SECTOR AS OPPOSED TO
CHARITY.
YOUNG THIS OF NOT SO THAT AS AN
INVESTMENT.
I WILL MEET WHEN WE TALK ON THE
TERMS IN WHICH YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT AS A THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND AND DOCTOR WIENER.
IN IN TERMS OF THE WORK FORCE
BOTH HIRING AND RETENTION. THERE
WAS A BILL LAST YEAR BUT IT WAS
VETOED BY MISS A VICE A MEMBER
EXHAUST FLETCHER. THAT WOULD
REQUIRE LARGE EMPLOYERS.
NEED TO DISCLOSE SPECIFIED INFO
ON GENDER WAGE DIFFERENTIALS TO
THINK THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR
WOULD BE HELPFUL.
I'M WE DEFINITELY THINK THAT.
KNOWING NUMBERS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THE MORE TRANSPARENCY
THERE IS THAT THESE COMPANIES
THE BETTER BECAUSE I OFTENTIMES
IT JUST BECOMES A. ISSUE OF WELL
WE'RE WORKING ON THE PROBLEM.
WHERE WE'RE DOING ALL THESE
EFFORTS BUT?
NO ONE KNOWS WHAT.
ANYTHING IS ACTUALLY PRODUCING
CHANGE WE DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
WORKING ARTS NOT WORKING OR IS
JUST WINDOW DRESSING FOR OR NOT
ACTUALLY PRODUCING ANY CHANGE SO
WE'RE DEFINITELY.
PROPONENTS OF MORE TRANSPARENCY
IN DIVERSITY NUMBERS AND WHAT
ACTUALLY.
IS HAPPENING WITHIN TECH
COMPANIES.
I THANK YOU.
FOR.
LEAD IN THAT CONVERSATION
AROUND THAT DRESSING BIAS IN THE
WORKPLACE AND CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WOMEN AND
YOUNG WOMEN.
IN PERHAPS WHEN TECHNICOLOR'S
UP THAT IN THEIR PART OF THE
PRESENTATION THEY CAN TALK
ABOUT.
HOW TO EXPAND THOSE HANDS ON
OPPORTUNITIES YOU KNOW A LOT OF?
SCHOOLS HAVE MAKERS SPACES.
BUT MANY DON'T AND I KNOW THAT
MY DAUGHTER WHO IS ELEVEN YEARS
OLD LOVES TO MAKERS SPACE HOW DO
WE MAKE IT SO THAT EVERY
STUDENT.
GETS ACCESS TO THAT PERHAPS
TECHNIQUE CAN SPEAK TO THROUGH
THEIR MEMBERSHIP OF THEIR WAYS
TO PARTNER.
WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS AROUND
THE IDEA OF CREATING THE SAME
TYPES OF HANDS ON OPPORTUNITIES
THAT YOU
THAT YOU'VE ADDRESSED.
WE LIKE TO ASK IF YOU HAVE THE
TIME TO STAY THERE MAY BE OTHER
QUESTIONS THROUGHOUT THE HEARING
WE APPRECIATE WHAT YOU SHARED
YOUR AND YOUR RESEARCH.
AND YOUR PILOT AND WOULD LOVE
TO LEARN MORE ABOUT ITWITH OUR
WORKING GROUP TO SEE IF WE CAN
CONTINUE. TO WORK WITH YOU AS
YOU AT THE MET YOUR FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I NEXT WEEK WILL CALL.
OUT TO DISCUSS SOME MEDICINE
PROGRAMS IN CHALLENGES.
A DAVID KING. WHO IS DIRECTOR
DIVERSITY IN BELONGING AT
AIRBNB?
AB NEETA SIVA MONEY WHO IS THE
CO FOUNDER AND C. E. O.. AT DAM
BETA. AND ALICIA PREGGO WAS VICE
PRESIDENT STRATEGIES BE SIXTY
AND IS HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
VERIZON WIRELESS.
WE WELCOME YOU TO COME TO.
THE PANEL STABLE.
READY FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS
WHEN YOU ARE.
I THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
MY NAME IS DAVID KING.
THE DIRECTOR FOR DIVERSITY AT
AIRBNB.
A PROGRAM THAT'S BEEN IN PLACE
FOR ABOUT TWO YEARS I CAME ONE
TWO YEARS AGO.
AND ALSO IT OFF BY TALKING
ABOUT.
DIVERSITY ON THE OUTSIDE OF THE
ORGANIZATION AND THEN THE INSIDE
OF THE ORGANIZATION.
A BIG PART OF THE REASON IS.
ABOUT YEARS AGO WE FACED SOME
ISSUES OF RACISM HOMOPHOBIA ON A
PLATFORM.
I REALLY HAD TO LOOK AT
DIVERSITY FROM A VERY DIFFERENT.
RESPECTIVE IN SOME ORGANIZATIONS
WHERE WE HAD A PROBLEM. THAT WAS
AFFECTING THE USERS OF OUR
PRODUCT.
BUT IMAGINE BEING BLACK AND NOT
BEING SELECTED FOR AIRBNB BASED
NICOLE OF YOUR SKIN.
OR BEING GAY AND SHOWING UP TO
AN AIR BEING BEING BEING TOLD
I'M SORRY YOU CANNOT STAY IN MY
HOME.
RIGHT SO WE BUILT A PLATFORM
WITHOUT THINKING ABOUT.
POTENTIAL BUYERS ON THAT
PLATFORM.
SO CONCURRENT LEADS TO THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING INTERNALLY
WHICH I'LL TALK ABOUT AS
RELEASED TO RECRUITMENT
RETENTION WE HAD TO REALLY TELL
THE WORLD WHO WE ARE AS A
COMPANY.
BUT OUR MISSION IS ABOUT BELONG
THEY WANNA MAKE SURE THAT IF YOU
WANT TO BE A MEMBER OF OUR
COMMUNITY. THAT YOU BUY INTO.
OUR CONSTRUCT OF BELONG AND
THAT MEANS IF YOU ARE BIASES
RELEASE RACISM HOMOPHOBIA
TRANSPHOBIA WE DON'T WANT YOU IN
A PLATFORM.
WE MADE A BOLD STATEMENT IN LATE
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO OUR
ENTIRE COMMUNITY BASICALLY
STATING THAT IF YOU DO NOT.
WE'LL LEAVE AND THE
UNDERPINNINGS OF WHY WE EXIST WE
DON'T WANT ONE A PLATFORM AND
SOME PEOPLE DID LEAVE. SOME
PEOPLE FRANKLY LEFT THE PLATFORM
SAYING I WANT TO LET ANYONE IN
MY HOME BUT I CHOOSE TO BE MY
HOME VERSES WHO USE AN
ORGANIZATION SAY CAN BE A MILE.
BUT THAT WAS TOUGH BUT WE REALLY
DID HAVE A PLAYBOOK.
THERE WAS NOT A COMPANY OUT
THERE IT REALLY ADDRESS THIS
THIS ISSUE HEAD ON.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THERE WAS
QUITE A BIT OF CHATTER OF IT YOU
TOLD THE WORLD WE YOUR IS A
COMPANY THAT WAS A SUPERBOWL
COMMERCIAL ETCETERA BUT WOULD
YOU DOING INSIDE. THE
ORGANIZATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU ADVANCE DIVERSITY CONSTRUCTS
THROUGHOUT THE ORGANIZATION THE
COMMUNITY.
A THE FIRST THING WE DID FRANKLY
WAS BUILT AN ANTI DISCRIMINATION
AND DIVERSITY TEAM.
SO THE EFFORTS THAT WE ARE GOING
BACK TWO YEARS THERE IS NOW AN
EVERGREEN TEAM IN PLACE WHOSE
JOB IT IS TO LOOK AT OUR
PLATFORM DALY. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WERE EXTRACTED BY SUMMER
PLATFORM.
BUT INCLUDES ENGINEERS DATA
SCIENTISTS PEOPLE GLOBALLY
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHO'S BEING
ACCEPTED. WHO'S NOT WHY IN IF
THERE ARE PROBLEMS MAKING SURE
WE ADDRESS THEM IN A RADICALLY
BIAS IN THE PLATFORM WE FIND OUT
THAT EXISTS.
INTERNALLY THERE IS A A GROUP OF
ABOUT FIVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DIRECTLY ON THE DIVERSITY AND
BELONGING TEAM BUT FOR ME IT'S
REALLY.
S. GALVANIZING THE ENTIRE
ORGANIZATION TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE ALL THINKING ABOUT
DIVERSITY AS AN ORG.
AND SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE DONE IS TO ATTRACT BY SOME
INTERVIEWS PERFORMANCE REVIEWS
AND OTHER PEOPLE PRACTICES THAT
YOU HEARD FROM MY CLAIMING
COLLEAGUE EARLIER.
WE HAVE A DIVERSE CANDIDATES
SLATE SIN IN PLACE WHICH IS
BASICALLY.
THE ROONEY RULE THAT THE NFL
ADOPTED ABOUT TWENTY YEARS AGO
STATING THAT WE MUST HAVE
DIVERSE SLATES OF CANDIDATES OR
INSIGHTS ONE SITE FOR INTERVIEWS
AND IF NOT. YOU NEED TO GO BACK
AND FIND THAT DIVERSITY AND IS
AN ALGORITHM USED TO DEFINE
WOULD ADVERSELY IT LOOKS LIKE.
I WE HAVE TRAINING THAT ARE IN
PLACE WHICH LIKELY MADONNA.
COLLEAGUE ALSO SPOKE ABOUT
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS WHICH A LOT OF
ORGANIZATIONS ARE DOING. ROSSO
DOING ALLY SKILLS TRAININGS
INTERNALLY BUT WE'RE ALSO DOING
WHICH I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IS MAKING SURE THAT WE
INTEGRATE DIVERSE CONSTRUCTS AND
TO ALL TRAININGS. SO DIVERSITY
TRAININGS ARE NOT SEEN AS THIS
ONE OFF THING OVER HERE WERE YOU
TAKEN UNCONSCIOUS BY TRAINING
AND SUDDENLY YOU'RE OKAY.
YOU'RE FREE OF BIAS AND YOU'RE
GOOD TO GO MAKING SURE THAT ALL
OF OUR TRAININGS WE'RE LOOKING
AT ALL OVER TRAINS TO MAKE SURE
THERE ARE DIVERSE CONSTRUCTS
EMBEDDED. IN THAT BUYS IS
EXTRACTED.
EMPLOYEE ENGAGEMENT SURVEYS WE
ARE WE DO PULL SURVEYS AN ANNUAL
SURVEYS OF OUR EMPLOYEES.
I WITH ABOUT FIFTEEN QUESTIONS
GEARED DIRECTLY TOWARDS
DIVERSITY IN BELONGING.
AND FOR YEARS FOR THE FIRST
THREE YEARS AGO IN THAT SURVEY
THE DIVERSITY RESPONSES WERE
VERY HIGH.
BUT THESE WERE NOTS OF THE MOST
DIVERSE POPULATIONS RESPONDING
TO THE SURVEY SO THIS PAST YEAR
FOR THE FIRST TIME. WE TOOK THAT
SURVEY DATA AND BROKEN DOWN BY
RACE
GENDER AND ETHNICITY AND WE
SOLVE CHALLENGES.
WE SAW THAT BLACK EMPLOYEES DID
NOT FEEL LIKE THEY BELONG TO ANY
ORGANIZATION TO THE SAME LEVEL
THAT WHITE EMPLOYEES DID. THAT
WOMEN DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY
BELONG TO THE SAME LEVEL THAT
MEN DO. SO MAKING SURE THAT WE
TAKE ALL OF OUR PEOPLE PRACTICES
AND BREAK IT DOWN BY ALL THE
CONFLICTS WERE TRYING TO ADDRESS
TO ALSO INCLUDE EQUAL PAY.
EQUIPED HOUSES WE DO ANNUALLY
AND WE'VE TOLD OUR EMPLOYEES IF
WE SEE ANY GAPS WE WILL ADDRESS
THOSE ACCORDINGLY. BUT ONE THING
WE STARTED ON THIS PAST YEAR IS
MAKING SURE. THAT WE LOOK AT
ETHNICITY AND RACE
AS WELL AS GENDER I THINK WE ALL
KNOW ABOUT THE SEVENTY NINE
CENTS TO THE DOLLAR. THAT WOMEN
VERSUS MEN ABA WE DON'T TALK
QUITE A BIT ABOUT ABOUT HOW
WREATH RACE AND ETHNICITY PLAY
IN PEOPLE PLAY ALSO. AND.
PART OF OUR OUR OUR DUTY
INTERNALLY IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DO ADDRESS GAPS IN THE EXIST.
WE'RE ALSO EXPANDING WHAT WE
MEASURE BEYOND THE EOC
REQUIREMENTS.
THE EEO ONE REPORT WHICH HAS
BEEN MENTIONED A FEW TIMES
ALREADY THIS MORNING.
DOES LOOK AT RACE SUCH RACE
GENDER AND ETHNICITY WERE ALSO
LOOKING INTERNALLY AT SEXUAL
ORIENTATION IDENTITY PARENTAL
STATUS DISABILITY AND VETERAN
STATUS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THAT DATA. AND WE CAN MEASURE OF
BELONGING ONCE AGAIN INTERNALLY
BASED ON CONSTRUCTS ABOVE AND
BEYOND THE SEA MANDATE.
WORKING WITH OUTSIDE
ORGANIZATIONS TO HELP US DO THIS
WORK WE CAN DO THIS ALL BY
OURSELVES SO WORKING WITH THE
CLAIMANT INSTITUTE. ARE WORKING
WITH LEAN AND SLASH MCKENZIE
WITH THE WOMEN IN THE WORKPLACE
SURVEY WHICH WE'VE DONE TWO
YEARS IN A ROW NOW AIRBNB.
AND WORKING WITH THE HUMAN
RIGHTS CAMPAIGN CORPORATE
EQUALITY INDEX LOOKING AT LGBTQ
BELONGING IN THE ORGANIZATION.
AIRBNB CONNECTS WE CREATED OUR
OWN INTERNAL APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM WHICH EUROPE STARTING V.
TO THIS YEAR VERSION TO THIS
YEAR.
DEFINING.
A POPULATION BRINGING THEM IN
TRAINING THEM UP.
AS PART OF OUR OWN COTERIE AND
THEN IDEALLY RETAINING THAT
POPULATION BUT IF NOT AT THE END
OF THE DAY MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE GROWING THE COMMUNITY
OUTSIDE OF OUR WALLS. AND
PUTTING PEOPLE IN A POSITION TO
SUCCEED AT AIRBNB OR OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS.
EXPANDING EFFORTS GLOBALLY
QUITE OFTEN WHEN I GO TO OFFICES
OUTSIDE OF SAN FRANCISCO. THE
CONVERSATION IS DIVERSITY IS NOT
OUR THING.
SO IMAGINE DUBLIN OR SINGAPORE.
AND QUITE OFTEN WHEN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND THEY REALIZE
DIVERSITY IS A THING IN THOSE
LOCALES WHICH IS DIFFERENT THAN
IT IS IN SAN FRANCISCO.
SO WE BOTH THE GLOBAL DIVERSITY
AMBASSADOR PROGRAM WE HAVE
AMBASSADORS WHO WORK FOR US
AROUND THE WORLD TWELVE. IN A
TWENTY SEVEN OFFICES AROUND THE
WORLD AND THEY ARE HELPING US
DEFINE DIVERSITY. AND ARE
INTEGRATING DIVERSITY
PROGRAMMING IN THOSE OFFICES
SPECIFICALLY.
UP PARTNERSHIPS ONCE AGAIN WE
HAVE TO WE CAN'T DO THIS WORK BY
OURSELVES WE WORK WITH
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS DEATH
COLOR. BUT SHIP WHICH SOCIETY
FOR HISPANIC PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS.
WELL ASUS THE AMERICAN ENDING
INDIAN SCIENCE AND ENGINEERING
SOCIETY.
THE CLAIMANT INSTITUTE OF THE
ARTS WHICH IS AN ORGANIZATION
FOR YOUNG ADULTS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. AND SCRIPTED WHICH
IS.
PIPELINE PROGRAM PROVIDING
CODING OPPORTUNITIES TO MIDDLE
AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
WE'VE CREATED IN THE PAST NINE
MONTHS SUPPLIER DIVERSITY
PROGRAM WHERE WE ARE. ACTIVELY
BRINGING DIVERSE SUPPLIERS INTO
THE ORGANIZATION AS CONTRACTORS
AND VENDORS.
AND WE ALSO CREATED A MENTORSHIP
PROGRAM FROM SCRATCH INTERNALLY.
THAT MENTORSHIP PROGRAM WAS
PILOTED WITH OUR EMPLOYEE
RESOURCE GROUPS
OF WHICH IT'S A VERY DIVERSE
GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS. AND THAT
WILL GROWTH THROUGHOUT THE
ORGANIZATION AS WE MOVE
THROUGHOUT BEYOND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN.
AND THAT EMPLOYER RE SCORE
SOURCE GROUP SPACE WE HAVE
SIXTEEN GROUPS TOTALING FIFTEEN
HUNDRED MEMBERS. AND THOSE
MEMBERS ARE TIED TO A SENIOR
SPONSORED TYPICALLY SITS ON THE
C. SUITE.
AS GUIDANCE AND MENTORSHIP WITH
ORGANIZATION MOVING FORWARD.
BUT SOME OF THINGS THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP EARLIER THAN I'D LIKE
TO JUST TOUCH UPON BEFORE WE
HAVE A FEW NAY LATER. IS ARE
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES IN SPACE.
AND SOMETHING THAT I'VE SEEN
THAT QUITE OFTEN HAPPENS WITH
ORGANIZATIONS IS PLAYING WHAT I
CALL THE DIVERSITY OLYMPICS.
QUITE OFTEN ORGANIZATIONS LOOK
AT WOMEN WOMEN IN TECH FIRST.
AND THEN SECONDARILY BLACK LET
NEXT BOB RELATIONS
AND THEN MAYBE LGBTQ MAYBE
PEOPLE DISABILITIES AND I THINK
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES OF MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS CONCURRENTLY. AND
THERE WERE NOT PITTING GROUPS
AGAINST EACH OTHER THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE INTERSECTION AUDI
WITH THOSE GROUPS BRING TO THE
TABLE. AS BEING THE LEADING
VOICE SO TO SPEAK AS OPPOSED TO
THE DIFFERENCES THOSE GROUPS
BRING TO THE TABLE.
.
DIVERSITY IN MERGERS AND
ACQUISITIONS ARE QUITE OFTEN IF
WE ARE LOOKING. AT OTHER
COMPANIES TO ACQUIRE THOSE
COMPANIES ARE TYPICALLY SMALLER
THAN OUR EXISTING COMPANY
AIRBNB.
AND TYPICALLY LESS DIVERSE SO
HOW DO WE HAVE. OF THOUGHTFUL
MERGERS AND ACQUISITIONS WHILE
TAKING DIVERSITY IN
CONSIDERATION IS UNDOUBTEDLY A
CHALLENGE.
AND SOMETHING I TOUCHED UPON
EARLIER WAS EXPANDING OUR
EFFORTS GLOBALLY.
BUT GLOBALLY FOR ME FRIENDLY
MEANS OUTSIDE OF THE BAY.
OF THE CONVERSATION THAT WE HAVE
WITH EMPLOYEES AND IN NEW YORK
LOOKS VERY DIFFERENT THEN THE
EMPLOYEES IN SEATTLE WHICH LOOKS
DIFFERENT THAN LONDON LOOKS
DIFFERENT IN SOUTH AFRICA. SO
HOW DO WE HAVE GLOBAL
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
CONSTRUCT DIVERSITY THAT VARY BY
REGION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THAT OUT MISS
CEREMONY WE LOOK YOUR
PRESENTATION PERFECT THANK YOU.
I WILL THANK YOU FOR HAVING THIS
MEETING TODAY THINK IT'S SUCH AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO TAKE THAT. A
PERSONAGE OF TO HAVE THESE KINDS
OF CONVERSATIONS AND I CAN BRING
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE SPECTRUM
WHICH IS AN EARLY STATE START
UPS ARE REDUCED TO AND A HALF.
YEARS IN WE HAVE LESS THAN
TWENTY EMPLOYEES BUT I'VE KIND
OF BEEN ON BOTH ENDS SO I WENT
TO UC DAVIS FOR UNDERGRAD. SO
I'VE BEEN A RECIPIENT OF
RESOURCES IN EXPANDING MY MIND
SET TO NOW BE WHERE I AM TODAY
AND SO NOW A LOT OF MY FOCUS IS
ON. ENCOURAGING IN ADVANCING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MINORITIES AND
STEM. SO I AM ALSO THE FOR A CAN
OF ONE OF THE FOUNDING CO CHAIRS
OF MILLION WOMEN MENTORS
CALIFORNIA WHICH WILL BE
DISCUSSED LATER ON TODAY. BUT MY
START UP IS DURING THE THAT AND
WE'RE HEALTH TECH COMPANY
ADDRESSING THE EDUCATION GAP
BETWEEN AND PHYSICIANS AND
PATIENTS. INTERMETALLIC G..
AND SO WHEN I FIRST STARTED ARE
THE COMPANY I REALLY HONESTLY
THOUGHT THAT RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION WOULD BE SOMETHING
THAT JUST CAME REALLY NATURALLY
HOME I WAS NAIVE. IT ACTUALLY
TAKES A LOT OF EFFORT AND FOCUS
ON BUT IT'S REALLY JUST BUILT
INTO MY DNA SO I THINK FROM THE
GET GO WITHOUT A CULTURE AND
CONVERSATIONS THAT. YOU KNOW
MAKE IT AN AND WELCOMING
ENVIRONMENT AND TO ME THAT MEANS
AND THE ABILITY FOR IT NO MATTER
WHO'S WHAT SOMEBODY'S BACKGROUND
IS TO BE ABLE TO COME IN. HAVE
ACCESS TO RESOURCES ON GROWTH
OPPORTUNITIES AND ENGAGEMENT WE
DO THINGS LIKE INSTEAD OF GOING
TO SPORTS ACTIVITIES MAY BE
REVIEW SUCCULENTS AND WINE
TASTING NIGHT FOR OUR TEAM
BUILDERS SO WE JUST DO THINGS
THAT OPEN IT UP SO THAT
EVERYBODY FEELS WELCOME AND I I
HAVE CONVERSATIONS AND. WE
LITERALLY CALL IT OUT AND I SAY
YOU KNOW ARE YOU AS A MANAGER OF
X. Y. Z. TEAM ARE YOU CREATING
AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE EVERYBODY
HAS A VOICE EVERYBODY FEELS
COMFORTABLE. AND SO WE DO CHECK
INS TO KIND OF ADDRESS UNCUT ON
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS OR JUST HOW
THAT AWARENESS.
I'M SO THOSE THINGS HAVE BEEN
REALLY HELPFUL FOR US.
I THINK ALSO TO FOR OUT WE DO
PARTNERSHIP SO WELL AS I
MENTIONED WHEN I FIRST STARTED I
REALLY THOUGHT OH EVERYBODY'S
GONNA WANNA COME WORK FOR US.
BUT IT TURNS OUT WE HAVE TO BE
REALLY PROACTIVE SO WHEN WE
DIDN'T HAVE A SINGLE WOMAN A
WOMAN APPLY FOR ANY OF OUR
ENGINEERING POSITIONS I WENT OUT
TO THE DEANS OF UC DAVIS AND
SEXY AND I ASK THEM TO CENTER
JOB DESCRIPTION NOW. I'M I WORK
WITH MATT START TO DEVELOP
PARTNERSHIPS FOR INTERNSHIP
PROGRAMS WITH ALL THE LOCAL AND
UNIVERSITIES YOU SEE SEX STATE.
OF YOUR P. LUSTROUS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM.
I CONTACTED THE STUDENT CLUBS
SO THAT I KNEW THAT THESE.
GROUPS WERE KNOWING ABOUT WHO
WE WERE AND THAT WE WERE AT A
LOCAL OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO
EITHER INTERN FOR WORK WITH US.
NOW THAT WERE FEW YEARS AND
WE'RE GOING FURTHER UPSTREAM AS
I RECENTLY SPOKE AT THE AG
INNOVATION SYMPOSIUM IN FAT NOW
WE'RE HOSTING A GROUP OF YOU
CITY STUDENTS TO COME TO OUR
OFFICE. AND TO REALLY SEE AND
EXTEND THEIR LEARNING. WILL
SEVER REALLY EXTENSIVE.
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM SO WE HAVE
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE STUDENTS RIGHT
NOW FROM HIGH SCHOOL ALL THE WAY
TO MEDICAL SCHOOL DEPENDING ON
THEIR INTEREST AREA THEY GET
PAID WITH A MENTOR. OUR MOST
POPULAR ONE IS IN DERMATOLOGY
HOW THREE OF OUR INTERNS JUST
GOT PLACED INTO DURING RESIDENCY
WHICH WAS A HUNDRED PERCENTUP
PLACEMENT SUCCESS RATES ARE VERY
PROUD OF THAT. AND WE THEY WORK
ON A SPECIFIC PROJECT SO THEY
BUILD THEIR EXPERTISE IN THIS
CASE AUTHORSHIP AUTUMN.
ADD TO REALLY GET THEMSELVES OUT
THERE AND BUILD THEIR OWN
BACKGROUND AND EXPERIENCE TO BE
ABLE TO SHARE THAT.
I'M AND NOW WHAT WE'RE DOING
MORE AND MORE OF.
THAT'S GREAT AT THE COMPANY
LEVEL BUT NOW I'M LOOKING MORE
AT YOU KNOW HOW DO WE BUILD THIS
INNOVATION ECONOMY IN OUR
COMMUNITY. I THINK THERE'S A LOT
THAT CAN BE DONE AT THE MACRO
LEVEL ON BECAUSE WE'RE REALLY
JUST THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG TIP
TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
I THINK IT'S WORKING MORE WITH
LOOKING AT THE SUCCESS OF
INSTITUTIONS LIKE YOU CITY SO
THEY WERE JUST RECENTLY VOTED AT
THE TOP COLLEGE FOR WOMEN IN
STAND BY FORBES. AND THIS DIDN'T
HAPPEN OVERNIGHT SO I ACTUALLY
SERVED ON THE CHANCELLOR'S
GRADUATE AND PROFESSIONAL AND
STUDENT VICE RE COMMITTEE AS A
AS A GRAD STUDENT IN BUSINESS
SCHOOL. I WAS CHAIR OF THE
DIVERSITY IN RETENTION OF
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS SO I
REALLY GOT TO SEE SOME OF THE
FACTORS FIRST HAND. THAT LED TO
THIS GROWTH OMINOUS OUTCOME AND
IT REALLY CAME WITH ALL OF THE
THINGS ALREADY MENTIONED WHICH
IS DELIBERATELY AT ADDRESSING
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS LIKE I WROTE
THEY HAD WORKSHOPS. AND THAT
THEY'RE OPEN CONVERSATIONS THEIR
TOWN HALLS THE RIP FORUMS WE
WORK TO PREPARE FACULTY TVA'S
HIRING COMMITTEES SO I THINK NOW
WE SEE THE CULMINATION OF ALL
THAT. VERY PROACTIVE AND
TANGIBLE EFFORT.
SO I THINK WE CAN CONTINUE TO
SCALE THAT OTHER OTHER AT OTHER
SCHOOLS AND ALSO OTHER COMPANIES
IN THE REGION.
I ALSO THINK JUST ON THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT SIDE
THERE'S MORE WE CAN DO TO INVEST
IN PROGRAMS LIKE RAILS WITCHES
RAPID ACCELERATION INNOVATION
LEADERSHIP. AND THEY SUPPORT THE
LOCAL ENTREPRENEURIAL ECOSYSTEM
SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO FUND
PROGRAMS LIKE THAT THAT'S GREAT
NOT ONLY FOR THE PIPELINE AND SO
BUT ALSO JUST TO HELP COMPANIES
LIKE INE SCALE. AND SO WITH
THAT I WOULD LOVE TO ALSO ALSO
PERFECT HUMAN NAY BUT I'M
EXCITED THAT WE'RE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION I THINK WE'VE MADE
PROGRESS AND THERE'S A LOT MORE
WE CAN DO TOGETHER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH DO ONE
ANNOUNCES THAT.
MOST MEMBERS WILL HAVE TO LEAVE
IN THE NEXT TWENTY OR SO MINUTES
BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME STANDING
MEETINGS AT ALL MEMBERS GO TO SO
I'M JUST BRIEF. PRESENTATION SO
THAT WE CAN HEAR FROM THE THIRD
PANEL WE DO WHEN HEAR FROM THEM
I'LL HAVE TO LEAVE THE NEXT TEN
TO FIFTEEN MINUTES.
THANK YOU FOR THAT MS PREGGO WE
WELCOME YOUR. PRESENTATION ON
BEHALF OF RICIN.
GREAT THANKS FOR HAVING ME AND
I'LL I'LL KEEP MY AND COMIC
SHORT THAT KNOWING THAT THERE'S
PLACES TO BE. SO THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY TODAY
AND BE PART OF THIS AND MEETING
PAN ALL MY NAME ALICIA PRIEGO
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF ALL
RIGHT THEN. BRYSON IS COMMITTED
TO FOSTERING AN INCLUSIVE
ENVIRONMENT AND WE CARE ABOUT
DIVERSITY IN BOTH OUR EMPLOYEES
AND OUR SUPPLIERS. AND DIVERSITY
AND INCLUSION IT'S CRITICAL TO
HOW WE ACHIEVE SUCCESS AND WE'RE
ALWAYS STRIVING FOR IMPROVEMENT.
I'M CURRENTLY THERE'S FIFTY NINE
PERCENT DIVERSITY IN VERIZON'S
WORKFORCE AND SIX OF OUR TWELVE
BOARD.
SIX OF OUR TWELVE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS ARE WOMEN AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN FRIDAY
HAS SPENT APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS WITH
DIVERSE SUPPLIERS WERE
CONTINUOUSLY SEEKING
OPPORTUNITIES TO WORK A MINORITY
WOMEN DISABILITY OWNED BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES VETERANS SERVICE
DISABLED VETERAN OR LGBT ON
BUSINESSES. AND WE EXPECT ARE
PRIMED TO DO THE SAME. AS PART
OF OUR EFFORT TO INCREASE
DIVERSITY WE ALSO WORK TO
IDENTIFY INCLUSIVE PARTNERS THAT
I HAD THE OTHER PANELISTS AND
HAVE NOTED AS AS BEING AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE SOLUTION.
ONE EXAMPLE IS ARE PARTNERING
WHEN I'M A PROJECT CALLED
PROJECT LEAD THE WAY. IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN WE JOIN PROJECT LEAD THE
WAY WHICH IS THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDE THE
TRANSFORMATIVE IN SCHOOL
LEARNING EXPERIENCE FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS. WE'VE
COMMITTED OVER FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO PROVIDING
FREE TECH ACCESS AND INNOVATED
LEARNING PROGRAMS. I WOULD JUST
THE FIRST TEN THOUSAND STUDENTS
I'M FORTY FOUR PERCENT WERE
GIRLS AND FIFTY TWO PERCENT WERE
FROM UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
GROUPS.
AND.
RIGHT AND PARTNERED WITH THIS
IMPORTANT PROGRAM DECREE OP
OPPORTUNITIES NECESSARY TO
INCREASE THE NUMBERS OF WOMEN
AND MINORITIES PURSUING STEM
DEGREES.
AND THIS CONTINUES TO BE A FOCUS
AND PRIORITY AND.
IN WHICH WE PROVIDE INVESTMENT
I'M FIVE YEARS AGO OF RIGHTS AND
LAUNCH THE INNOVATIVE LEARNING
INITIATIVE AGAIN PROVIDING FREE
TECHNOLOGY FREE ACCESS AND
INNOVATIVE CURRICULA TO BUILD A
BRIGHTER FUTURE FOR MILLIONS OF
KIDS. AND PART OF THE SCHOOL
THAT IS RECEIVING AND THAT'S AN
ONGOING TEACHER TRAINING
CURRICULUM GUIDES TABLETS AND
FOUR G. LTE LTE DATA PLAN.
PSALM ALSO RECEIVE INNOVATION
LADS OUTFITTED WITH THE LATEST
EQUIPMENT AND CONNECTIVITY. AND
STUDENTS IN THIS PROGRAM HAVE
DEMONSTRATED.
INCREASE PROFICIENCY IN READING
AND MATH WITH THE MAJORITY OF
STUDENTS MORE ENGAGED IN SCHOOL.
AND AFTER TWO YEARS RIGHT THEN
THOUGHT THAT STUDENTS IMPROVED
ON STANDARDIZED TESTS AT RATES
HIGHER THAN THEIR PEERS THREE
TIMES FOR MATH AND TWO TIMES FOR
READING.
IN FACT JUST YESTERDAY WE
ANNOUNCE THAT I WILL INVEST MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO GO
TOWARDS THESE INNOVATIVE
LEARNING PROGRAMS.
AND OUR OBJECTIVES AND CHANGED
SURE THAT ALL CHILDREN HAD EVERY
CONCEIVABLE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND MAKE A POSITIVE
IMPACT ON THE WORLD. AND BY
TWENTY TWENTY NEARLY EIGHT IN
TEN JOBS OR CRIER TECHNOLOGY
SKILLS AND WE MUST ALL WORK
TOGETHER TO PROVIDE EDUCATION
RESOURCES STUDENTS NEED. AND TO
BE SUCCESSFUL. LAUGHED FREE TO
DISRUPT THAT THAT I JUST WANTED
TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF RIGHT IN
THE COMP WHICH MEANT AND AWARDS
I'M FOR THE FOURTH CONSECUTIVE
YEAR OF RIGHT THAT WAS
RECOGNIZED BY THE BLACK
ENTERPRISE MAGAZINE FOR SEEING
THE VALUE OF THE LINK BETWEEN
DIVERSITY ENGAGEMENT AND NAMED
ONE OF. THE BEST CUT COMPANIES
FOR DIVERSITY IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WITH THE WORKPLACE
EXCELLENCE AND DIVERSITY AWARD.
AND IN ADDITION FOR SEVEN
CONSECUTIVE YEARS THE US HAS
MANIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
RECOGNIZE RIGHT IN FOR OVER ONE
BILLION. AND AND INVESTMENTS AND
HISPANIC BUSINESS ENTERPRISES.
AND THOSE ARE JUST TAKE NOTE A
COUPLE OF OUR ADD. UP
PARTNERSHIPS AND INVESTMENTS IN
THE COMMUNITY AND VERY WHO LOOKS
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THAT
COMMITTEE ON THE ON THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE GREAT
EXAMPLES.
FROM VERIZON AND DON'T. AND
AIRBNB ON EFFORTS THAT ARE
REALLY ONGOING AND CREATIVE.
TO HELP US LAST DAM OUR
DIVERSITY GAPS.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS.
OUT WE INVITE YOU TO TO STAY
WITH US WE HAVE ONE MORE PANEL
WE'D LOVE TO HEAR ANYTHING ELSE
THAT YOU WISH TO OFFER BUT THANK
YOU FOR THOSE PRESENTATIONS.
I WOULD LIKE TO CALL FORWARD
FROM.
.
DISCUSS
SOME OF OUR FUTURE EFFORTS AND
TO BUILD ON WHAT WE JUST HEARD.
ANDREA DIVO VICE PRESIDENT A
STATE POLICY AND POLITICS AT
TECH NET.
GINA LU HAN THE FOUNDER AND CEO
OF HACKER LAB AND CO FOUNDER AND
CEO OF CODE FOR GOOD. AND LUPITA
ALCALA
THE COMMISSION OF FROM THE
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS.
WE WELCOME YOU WE ARE READY WHEN
YOU ARE.
SAID I READ IT ALL AND A SUPER
FAST OR JUST CUT TO THE CHASE.
ALRIGHT I MY COMMITTEE IS ALWAYS
THE CUTS WITH ALL RIGHT THERE
YOU GO THANK YOU CHAIRMAN.
CHAIRMAN AND MISTER HOLE IN
COMMITTEE ANDREA DEVOUT VICE
PRESIDENT OF STATE POLICY AND
POLITICS FOR TACK MATT. WE'RE
PROUD TO BE HERE TODAY I TECH
NOT REPRESENTS OVER EIGHTY OF
THE NATION'S LEADING TECHNOLOGY
AND INNOVATION COMPANIES.
AND WE ARE COMMITTED.
AND DEDICATED TO WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR LEADERS
THAT ARE BEFORE US TODAY AND
THOSE.
THAT ARE WILLING TO WORK WITH
US ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
SO THANK YOU FOR HOSTING THE
HEARING.
WE LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS I DO WANT TO NOTE
CHAIRMAN.
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE HEARING
YOUR DOUBTS THE WORKING GROUP
THAT YOU ESTABLISH WE HAD OUR
FIRST. MEETING I THINK IT WAS ON
THE TWENTY THIRD AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE NEXT MEETING ON
THE NINETEENTH AND GATHERING THE
RIGHT FOLKS TO REALLY START.
YOU KNOW CREATING A DIFFERENCE
ON BOTH WITHIN THE HALLS OF THE
CAPITOL AS WELL. AS WITHIN OUR
INDUSTRY SO THANKYOU FOR
INITIATING THAT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING EFFORTS THERE.
INTO IT SORT OF IN THAT THE
THEME OF CUTTING TO THE CHASE.
I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT ARE SOME OF OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES I'M HAVE DONE
AND ARE CONTINUING TO DO.
JUST AROUND THEIR COMMITMENT
AYE IN DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
SEVERAL OF OUR MEMBER COMPANIES
ALL LIST IF YOU CA TECHNOLOGIES
CISCO HP PAYPAL.
CENTER VISA AND SEAGATE HAVE
SIGNED ON TO THE CBO ACTION.
FOR DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
PLEDGE SO I'M NOT SURE IF YOU'RE
AWARE THAT SOME OF THE PRICE
WATER COOPER INITIATIVE THAT WAS
INITIATED BY TEN. CEOS AYE THAT
CAME TOGETHER ON AND THERE ARE
NOW OVER FOUR HUNDRED CEOS WHO
HAVE PLEDGED TO TAKE CONCRETE
ACTIONS TO INCREASE DIVERSITY.
INTENTIONALLY CULTIVATE
WORKPLACES THAT ARE INCLUSIVE
AND PUBLICLY REPORT THEIR
EFFORTS AND BASS BEST PRACTICES.
ALL OF A LARGE TECH COMPANIES WE
SURVEYED AND.
OVER THE LAST YEAR ACTUALLY
TECHNET HAS ENDEAVORED ARE SORT
OF A SELF APPOINTED EFFORT.
WHERE WERE? WE'VE BEEN TALKING
WITH A LOT OF OUR MEMBER COMPANY
SOME OF THIS PUBLIC INFORMATION
SOME OF AN INTERNAL AND
GATHERING THAT INFORMATION SO
THAT WE. AS TECHNO CAN BE
EDUCATED IN TERMS OF A WHAT
PROGRAMS ARE INSTITUTED WITHIN
OUR MEMBER COMPANIES ARE WHAT
PROGRAMS THEY'RE LOOKING AT. AYE
INSTITUTING AYE TO REALLY CREATE
A DIFFERENCE AND MAKE A
DIFFERENCE ON THIS ISSUE. SO.
AS WE WE DID THE SURVEY.
WE WE REALIZED THAT OUR MEMBER
COMPANIES HAVE INCREDIBLE
PROGRAMS NOT ONLY.
THAT HAVE BEEN UNDER WAY FOR
WHETHER IT'S BEEN FIVE SIX SEVEN
EIGHT TEN YEARS OR ARE BEING.
CONTEMPLATING INSTITUTED BASED
OFF OF THE GREAT RESEARCH SOME
OF WHAT YOU'VE HEARD HEARD FROM
TODAY AS WELL AS BEDS PRACTICES.
AS THAT GENTLEMAN FROM AIRBNB
DAVID KING TALKED ABOUT.
SO SOME COMMON TRAININGS FOR
NEW HIRES IN SENIOR LEADERSHIP
INCLUDE UNCONSCIOUS BIAS.
APPRECIATING DIFFERENCES AND THE
ECONOMIC ARGUMENT FOR DIVERSITY.
I THINK MISTER KALRA HAD ALLUDED
TO THAT.
FOR EXAMPLE OVER NINETY PERCENT
OF THESE IS LEADERSHIP HAVE
COMPLETED THEIR UNCONSCIOUS BIAS
TRAINING TODAY. A WHILE EVER HAS
FIVE THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
COMPLETING THEIR TRAINING.
MENTORING PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
DESIGNATED TO DEVELOP DIVERSE
SENIOR LEADERSHIP FROM WITHIN
THE COMPANY. AT HP IS SEVENTY
PERCENT OF THE PARTICIPANTS IN
THE CATALYST AT HP MENTORING
PROGRAM ARE WOMEN OR PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
SINCE FIRST LAUNCHING THE
PROGRAM SEVENTY EIGHT PERCENT OF
THE PROTEGES PROTEGES HAVE BEEN
PROMOTED ARE MOVED INTO NEW
POSITIONS AT HP.
VISA HAS ESTABLISHED THE V. SEXY
EXECUTIVE EDGE.
GLOBAL LEADERSHIP PROGRAM FOR
WOMEN DEVELOPED IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH UC BERKELEY HAAS SCHOOL OF
MINUTE BUSINESS THEY HAVE
TRAINED SIXTY PLUS WOMEN TODAY.
THESE ARE JUST A FEW EXAMPLES OF
OF TECHNET MEMBER COMPANIES
AGAIN SORT OF CUTTING TO THE
CHASE.
.
THIS COMMITMENT IS EMBEDDED IN
OUR CULTURE.
TECH COMPANIES ARE NOT ONLY
ESTABLISHING PROGRAMS
DEPARTMENTS AND ENTIRE
INITIATIVES TO SOLVE THIS ISSUE
OF DIVERSITY AND TALK WITH THEIR
WORKING TOWARDS IS BEING A PART
OF THE DNA.
THE FIRST STEP IS KNOWING YOU
HAVE A PROBLEM TO SOLVE.
WHERE THERE?
NOW WE'RE WORKING TOWARDS THE
SOLUTION IT WON'T HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT BUT WITH THE
PARTNERSHIPS OF THE INDUSTRY.
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM.
AND OUR ELECTED LEADERS WE'RE
NOT FAR FROM ACHIEVING OUR
COLLECTIVE GOAL OF EXCELLENCE
THROUGH EQUALITY IN OUR
WORKFORCE.
I CHAIRMAN THURMAN YOU
SPECIFICALLY I'M HAD PASSED
AROUND THE FINANCIAL SUPPORT
THAT DOCTOR FLOWERS HAD I HAD
ALLUDED TO IN RESPONSE TO MR
CALLER'S QUESTION. OF A COUPLE
OF EXAMPLES AROUND FINANCIAL
SUPPORT I CAN CERTAINLY PROVIDE
MORE I THINK THE WORKING GROUP
WOULD BE A GOOD PLACE FOR THIS.
THAT CA TECHNOLOGIES.
THEY HAVE PARTNERED WITH THE
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB OF AMERICA
AND CREATED TECH GIRLS ROCK.
WITH TEN MILLION DONATED SINCE
I TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE.
LIKEWISE THEY HAVE INCREDIBLE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH SESAME STREET
A ONE MILLION.
AS IT'S CALLED ONE MILLION
SESAME WORKSHOP AIMED AT AGES
THREE THROUGH FIVE SO AGAIN SORT
OF GETTING TO ARE WE JUST
TARGETING A CERTAIN SEGMENT OF.
OF KIDS ON THAT'S ALL AROUND
STEM LEARNING.
VERIZON TALK TODAY ABOUT THEIR
CITY OF SACRAMENTO EARMARKED
WITH TWENTY MILLION OR TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR PROGRAMS TO
INCREASE DIVERSITY AND TACK. UP
PUTS MATES FOR EXAMPLE DONATES
TWO DOLLARS RUMOR EVERY ORDER TO
THE ACLU JUST A FEW EXAMPLES
SORT OF AROUND THAT FINANCIAL
PEACE.
I AM I WANT TO BE RESPECTFUL OF
OUR FELLOW PANELISTS SO I HOPE
WILL END THERE I THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN AND LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
JUST BEING THE BEGINNING OF
THESE CONVERSATIONS AND
CONTINUING. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THAT MISTER BILL AND ALSO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK TO HELP
US PULL TOGETHER OF THE PARTNERS
WHO CAME TO BE A PART OF THE
WORKING GROUP AND. THE LIST OF
RESOURCES THAT YOU JUST
DESCRIBED AND PERHAPS YOU CAN
HELP US CONNECT SOME. DISTRICTS
THAT MIGHT BE INTERESTED IN.
CONNECTING WITH THOSE RESOURCES
TO HELP THEM EXPAND THEIR
PROGRAMS.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU.
AND I WANNA.
KNOWLEDGE ONE OF THE PARTNERS
HAS BEEN WORKING WITH OUR GROUP
AND WE APPRECIATE HAVING YOU
KNOW LOU HAN HERE.
AND.
AND KEEP THE ALCALA.
IN A MOMENT I'M HAVE TO THE
THEY APOLOGIZE IF I DON'T GET TO
HEAR ALL YOUR PRESENTATION BUT
WE WELCOME. YOU TO BE PART OF
OUR ONGOING EFFORT TO THE
WORKGROUP.
OUR VICE CHAIR.
SOME OF THEM FLOOR IS GOING TO
CUT TAKE THE CONVERSATION FROM
HERE AND IF YOU ALL HAVE ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS. THEY'LL MAKE
SURE THAT WE INCORPORATE THOSE
INTO THE WORKING GROUP AND FROM
MOVING FORWARD.
SO I'M SURE THAT.
MISS NOHA READY.
HELLO I'M GENERALLY HAUNTED I'M
CEO OF HACKER LAB AND CODE FOR
HOOD.
.
THIS IS A VERY NEAR AND DEAR
TOPIC FOR ME I'M ACTUALLY I'M A
TEENAGE A FORMER TEENAGE RUNAWAY
I HAD FIVE KIDS BY THE TIME I
WAS TWENTY TWO. AND I LEGALLY
HAVE A SEVENTH GRADE EDUCATION.
THAT'S LAST GREAT I COMPLETED
ACTUALLY I WENT TO SCHOOL LATER
BUT AS FAR AS BEING AND AT
SCHOOL. ARM I WAS ON THE WELFARE
TO WORK PROGRAM AND WHAT CHANGE
MY LIFE WITH LEARNING HOW TO
CODE WHEN I WAS TWENTY SIX YEARS
OLD.
AND WE RUN A PROGRAM MY CO
FOUNDERS OVER THERE ALLEN WHERE.
AND THAT ORGANIZATION A
NONPROFIT CALLED CODE FOR HOOD
ATLANTIS HAD MANY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND DONE SOME
REALLY GREAT THINGS HERE IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND STATEWIDE. DOING
THINGS ON IN REGARDS TO
EDUCATION WE HOLD STE.
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN LOW
COST VERY AT ENTRY LEVEL
TECHNOLOGY CLASSES A MONTH WE
ALSO OFFER LOW COST INCUBATION
SPACE AND. BY THEN A THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN EQUIPMENT AND WE ALSO
PARTNER WITH EDUCATIONAL AND
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS.
OUR WORK WITH YOUR COLLEGE LED
TO OUR MAKER SPACES GETTING
FUNDING FOR THE WHOLE CITY
CALIFORNIA IN. IN RESPECT TO
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS SO NOW
THERE'S TWENTY SCHOOLS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I'M
COMMITTEE COLLEGES THAT HAVE
MAKERS SPACES DUE TO THE WORK
THAT HACKER LAB IS DONE.
CODE FOR HOOD I'M GOES INTO.
UNDER REPRESENTED NEIGHBORHOODS
AND WE DO HACKATHONS WORKSHOPS
AND BOOT CAMPS WE OFFER AFTER
SCHOOL ON SERVICES AS WELL AND
WE PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON. ON LOW
INCOME AND CHILDREN OF COLOR
ITEM AND OFFER THEM A QUALITY
AND ACCESS WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR THREE YEARS NOW AND HAVE
SERVED OVER TWO THOUSAND
CHILDREN. ON AND THIS IS THIS IS
WHAT WE DO AND IT IS VERY IT'S A
VERY MUCH NEEDED. AYE AND.
MUCH NEEDED RESOURCES IN THESE
AREAS AND IN REGARDS TO.
LACK OF EDUCATION IN STEM LACK
OF RESOURCES AND.
.
LACK OF PARENTAL SUPPORT AS FAR
AS THEIR EDUCATION AND KNOWLEDGE
OF HOW IMPORTANT STEM IS FOR
THEIR CHILDREN. ON IT STARTS AT
HOME AYE I DO SEE THERE'S A BIG
BARRIER.
WHEN IT COMES TO PARENTS
ACTUALLY THINKING THAT THEIR
CHILDREN CAN ACCOMPLISH THE
THINGS THAT ACTUALLY DOES
STARTED HOME ESPECIALLY THE
HISPANIC COMMUNITY COMING FROM A
VERY BLUE COLLAR BACKGROUND.
ITEMS STATING FACTS LIKE OWE ME
HOW YOU'RE SO. A YEAR SO YOU
THINK YOU'RE SUCH A BIG CHIN
GOING BECAUSE YOU WANT TO BECOME
AN ENGINEER AND SO THEY ACTUALLY
GET CHASTISED AND MADE FUN OF
BECAUSE THEY ONE ACTUALLY GO TO
COLLEGE YOU BECOME AN ENGINEER.
OR BECOME AND ACTUALLY HAVE A
FAMILY MEMBER WHO WENT TO THE
MILITARY BECAUSE HE WANTED TO GO
TO COLLEGE TO BECOME AN AERONAUT
ERIC. ARROW NOT ACHE.
I ENGINEER AND HIS FATHER
TOTALLY LAUGHED AT HIM AND HE
ENDED UP BECOMING.
BOB MILITARY POLICE AND ARMY THE
HIGH PATROLMAN BUT HE WANTED TO
BE AN ENGINEER
SO ON THESE THINGS ACTUALLY DO
STARTED HOME. THERE'S OF HUGE
LACK OF RESOURCES WHEN IT COMES
TO ON PROVIDING THIS TYPE OF
EDUCATION BECAUSE OF THE FUNDS
THAT NEEDS. THAT IS NEEDED TO
ACTUALLY GOING TO THESE THE
SCHOOLS AND PERFORM EDUCATION ON
IT. WHICH STEM CURRICULUM.
SO.
WERE HOPING THAT WE'LL BE ABLE
TO ADD MORE RESOURCES AS WE GO
WHERE IN THE MIDDLE OF WORK
TRYING TO GET INTO THE FRIDGE
COMMUNITY CENTER SOMEWHERE IN
SOUTH SACRAMENTO. SO WE ACTUALLY
CAN PROVIDE A MAKERS SPACE FOR
THE YOUTH IN THOSE AREAS ON
YOU'LL HEAR MORE FROM ALLEN
LATER HE ACTUALLY TEACHES ON THE
STUDENTS EVERY WEEKEND. ON I
JUST I JUST DO THIS THING AND
THIS IS THE RIGHT TO SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
I'LL LEAVE IT TO THEM TO BE
RESPECT.
THANK YOU FOR DOING WHAT YOU DO
AND WHAT YOU SHARED ABOUT
OVERCOMING AND THAT'S A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF WHAT WE CAN DO FOR
OUR STUDENTS THANK YOU.
SADDAM.
THE MORNING LOOK AT THAT PROCESS
OF COLOR I M. A COMMISSION ON
THE COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS. AND.
MY DAY JOB IS THAT I AM AT THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION OF MY INTEREST IN
LOVE OF STEM EDUCATION AND
PARTICULARLY GIRLS AND
UNDERREPRESENTED YOUTH THAT WAS.
BORN FROM MY TIME SPENT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IS ABOUT
TWELVE YEARS THERE LAST SERVING
AS THE DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
INSTRUCTION AND LEARNING. UP I
JUST LOOK AT THE NUMBER SO WHAT
I WANT TO TALK TO YOU TODAY'S
REALLY QUICK ABOUT GROUND ZERO A
WHICH COULD BE IN THE HOME BUT
ALSO IN K. TWELVE EDUCATION AND
THE DISPARITY. IN EQUITIES START
REALLY YOUNG.
IN COURSEWORK AND SO I KNOW
THAT I PASSED OUT A A LITTLE
POWER POINT AND YOU CAN'T SEE
AND I APOLOGIZE BUT I'LL READ
YOU WHAT THE NUMBERS ARE.
.
WE'VE AYE AT THE AS THE
COMMISSION OF THE SETTLEMENT
GROWTH WE FOCUS ON STEM
EDUCATION NOT. OF JUST BECAUSE
OF MY INTEREST BUT THE ENTIRE
COMMISSION IS INTERESTED THROUGH
OUR CO SPONSORSHIP FOR THE STEAM
SYMPOSIUM WITH DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. OF AS WELL TOWN HALL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND THAT'S
IN MY PRESENTATION BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT SLIDE THREE. AND YOU
LOOK AT THE CALIFORNIA MALE TO
FEMALE STUDENT RATIOS WE COULD
HAVE THE VERY SAME SORT OF
RATIOS BUT WORSE IF YOU COMPARED
TO UNDERREPRESENTED YOUTH AND
STUDENTS OF COLOR. SO WHAT WE'RE
SHOWING HERE IS THAT THERE ARE
GENDER STEREOTYPES EVEN AS EARLY
AS K. TWELVE EDUCATION NOW THE
RATIO OF MALES TO FEMALES TURNS
OUT IT'S ONE POINT ZERO FOUR TWO
ONE. SO THE SCIENCE IS ABOUT
ACCURATE.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT COMPUTER
PROGRAMMING I'VE BEEN STUDYING
THIS FOR FOUR YEARS.
AND THIS IS OUR CURRENT NUMBERS
OF TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN.
IT'S TWO POINT SIX THREE TWO ONE
THOUGHTS ABOUT NUMBER SAYS
THERE'S STILL MORE THAN DOUBLE
MALE TO FEMALE RATIO IF YOU LOOK
AT COMPUTER EDUCATION ABOUT ONE
POINT FIVE SEVEN TO ONE.
ENGINEERING IS ONE POINT FIVE
SEVEN ONE WE HAVE MADE HEADWAY
OF WHAT WE'VE.
WHAT I WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW
IS AND COMPUTER EDUCATIONAL LAST
FOR YEARS WE'VE BEEN CREWS ABOUT
FIVE THOUSAND GIRLS IN COMPUTER
EDUCATION? ENGINEERING WE'VE
ACTUALLY INCREASED ABOUT EIGHT
THOUSAND GIRLS.
OF SCIENCE IS ABOUT THE SAME
WOULD ON AN INCREASE BUT
PROPORTIONALLY BECAUSE WE'VE HAD
MORE ENROLLMENT AND STUDENT WITH
ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND.
MORE GIRLS A COMPUTER
PROGRAMMING HAS GONE FROM THREE
POINT ZERO SEVEN TO ONE THAT WAS
FOUR YEARS AGO. TO TWO POINT SIX
FIVE TO ONCE A WEEK THERE'S BEEN
ONLY A FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
GIRLS INCREASE.
NOW THERE HAS ALSO TO DO WITH A
SPECIALIZED COURSES HAVE BEEN
CREATED LIKE INFORMATION
COMMUNICATION TECHNOLOGIES WHICH
ARE SKEWED THAT THAT NUMBER
SLIGHTLY. BUT WHAT I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT IS THAT THOSE BIASES
OF YOU KNOW YOU'VE SEEN A LOT OF
THE NUMBERS FOR SUSPENSIONS AND
EXPULSIONS ONCE THOSE NAY IN
THOSE NUMBERS COME TO LIFE BY
ETHNICITY. IT'S AMAZING HOW
PEOPLE TAKE PAY ATTENTION RIGHT
AND SO WHILE I HAVE THESE
NUMBERS COURSE WORK SO WE CAN
GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF WHERE
IT'S HAPPENING AND HOW EARLY
IT'S HAPPENING IN TERMS OF.
GIRLS AND UNDERREPRESENTED YOUTH
JUST BEING KIND OF TURNED AWAY
FROM SOME OF THIS COURSE WORK.
SO SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
I HAVE IS I KNOW YOU DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF TIME.
I WANT YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S IN
HERE IS THAT WE'VE OF POPULAR HE
HOSTED QUITE A FEW CO SPONSORED
A LOT OF THE STEAM SYMPOSIUMS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
WEAPON AMAZING INTERAGENCY
AGREEMENT WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DAVIS ON THE MILLION
WOMEN MENTORS. UP PROGRAM.
AND OF COURSE WE'VE IMPLEMENT
COLLUDED IN THE NEXT GENERATION
SCIENCE STANDARDS A SUPPORTING
EFFORTS IN CORPORATE GIRLS AND
YOUNG WOMEN INTO THE EQUITY IN
ACCESS FRAMEWORK.
TRAINING MODULE FOR ALL
TEACHERS WHICH IS REALLY
IMPORTANT ON A TO ADDRESS GENDER
BIAS BUT WHAT I WANTED TO ARE
ALSO TURNED LEAVE YOU WITH IS.
WHAT WE REALLY NEED IS TO
INCREASE THE DIVERSITY AND
MENTORSHIPS AND INTERNSHIPS?
WE ALSO SHOULD BE REQUESTING
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
ETHNICITY BY THESE COURSE WORK
SO THAT WE CAN SORT OF SLICE AND
DICE IT. OF FURTHER MAKERS
SPACES AS EARLY AS ELEMENTARY
AND MIDDLE SCHOOL.
ALSO THE WAY WE MARKET.
AND.
THESE COURSES FOR GIRLS AND
UNDERREPRESENTED YOUTH JUST THE
COLOR OF THE MARKETING YOU KNOW
POSTER OR THE NAME OF THE COURSE
ITSELF LIKE ENGINEERING AND
DESIGN FOR INSTANCE MAY APPEAL
TO WOMEN AND GIRLS.
AND OTHER STUDENTS OF COURSE
AND OF COURSE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
EVERY INDUSTRY HAS BIAS EVERY
SINGLE INDUSTRY NOT IN IN IN
TEACHING AND ADMINISTRATORS
THERE'S IS NO LESS OF THAT AND
SO PROVIDING MORE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
LIKE THESE MAKERS SPACES. IF
THERE COULD BE SOME SORT OF
OUTREACH EFFORT LIKE THERE WAS
AN HIGHER ADDING COMMITTEE
COLLEGE FOR K. TWELVE FOR MAKERS
SPACES MANY WANTED THEY JUST
DON'T KNOW HOW TO DO IT AND
THAT'S WHY. IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO.
CONTINUE AND I KNOW THAT WE'RE
RUNNING OUT OF TIME AND I
APOLOGIZE BUT MORE MY
INFORMATION IS IN THE SLIDES AND
I'LL HAVE TO JUST SHARE THE
FLIGHT DECK SO THAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY READ IT. UP BECAUSE
IT'S QUITE SMALL OF THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ALLOWING ESTA PRESENT
TODAY.
I THINK YOU WE WILL BE WORKING
TO INCORPORATE MANY THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM ALL THESE
PANELS WITH THE WORKING GROUP.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
WHAT IT KNOWLEDGE JOHNSON
COLLEAGUES WHO'VE JOINED US?
SOME WOMEN BLOOM NUMBER BONTA
GRAY PARTNERS WHO BEEN VERY
COMMITTED TO THE IDEAS OF
INCREASING DIVERSITY. IN TECH.
LET.
THE VICE CHAIR LEAD TO OTHER
ANY QUESTIONS AND IF NOT WILL
CLOSE OUT AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE DAY.
ARE INCORPORATED INTO THE
WORKING GROUP'S THINKING.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
NOW.
A QUESTIONS FROM THE AUDIENCE
ANYTHING CLOSE REMARKS.
ONE ANSWER.
OKAY.
OKAY OUT TRY TO BE RESPECTFUL
PEOPLE TOPIC FORGIVE ME UP TO
SPEAK.
I'M A TALK FAST SO I APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT ON THE FRONT AND MY
NAME IS ALAN WHERE. MOM I AM A
MECHANICAL ENGINEER HAVING GOT
MY BACHELOR OF SCIENCE IN
MECHANICAL ENGINEERING FROM
BAYLOR UNIVERSITY AND.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN OUR WORK FOR
ROCKWELL COLLINS A DEFENSE
CONTRACT WORK NOT BUT SIMULATORS
FOR B. FIFTY ONE B. FIFTY TWO
SEVEN THIRTY SEVENS BLACKHAWK
HELICOPTERS AND OTHER THINGS
LIKE THAT. UP AFTER THAT I WENT
AND WORKED FOR A COMPANY FIBER
SPAIN WHICH THE DISTRIBUTED
ANTENNA SYSTEMS ESSENTIALLY
HELPING CELLPHONE SIGNALS
GETTING TO PLACES. ARE WHERE YOU
CAN ONLY GO TO WORK IN A VERY.
ON A PILOT PROGRAM FOR THE MTA
BUILDING BOXES FOR TELECOM
COMPANIES.
EIGHTEEN T. T. MOBILE SPRINT
ALL OF THOSE TO HELP US CELL
PHONE SIGNAL GET TO THE EMPTY
EXCEPT SUBWAY LINE. UNTO DEATH
ELEVEN I MOVED TO A CALIFORNIA
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WAS GOING
ON FILM HACKER LAP IN A PRETTY
MUCH BEEN THEIR SENSE. OF
CURRENTLY A MEMBER OF HACKER LAP
FIFTEEN IMAGE AND I AM THE CHIEF
TECHNICAL OFFICER OF COBRA HOOD
WHERE I TEACH DO A LOT WITH
CURRICULUM. I'M ALSO AN ADJUNCT
FACULTY AT SIERRA COLLEGE GOING
IN MY THIRD SEMESTER TEACHING
INTRODUCTION TO THE PRINTING
THAT ADDITIVE MANUFACTURING
CLASS AND I ALSO DO A FREELANCE
DESIGN A MECHANICAL DESIGN AND
MANUFACTURING CONSULTING READING
THIS FORUM. FOR
ALLOWING US TO TALK.
AND JUST I WANT TO MAKE SURE
BEFORE THE INTO NEXT PART I WAS
ALWAYS TAUGHT TO A NOT BITE THE
HAND THAT FEEDS YOU. SO I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT I'M ADEPTLY
SAY EVERYTHING THEM BUT TO SAY
FROM.
FROM A I'M FEELING OF GRATITUDE
APPRECIATION ALSO WANNA GIVE
ABOUT GLORY REFERENCE TO GOD FOR
IT IS THROUGH HIS GRACE AND
MERCY YEAH BUT I HAD WHAT KIND
OF THE HEAD ON KILL SET NOW
MAYBE THIS MAY BE TWO
PRIVATE SUMMIT THAT. I WOULD
EXPECT I MUST WORK FOR A COMPANY
I'D BE PULLING ANYWHERE BETWEEN
EIGHTY THOUSAND OR TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
ANNUALLY.
BUT I'M NOT DOING THIS BECAUSE I
DO THIS BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT
TO ME.
IT'S IMPORTANT ME BECAUSE I GREW
UP IN EAST SAINT LOUIS ILLINOIS.
CHILD TO A SINGLE MOTHER WHO
WAS BIPOLARAND THAT IT WASN'T
EASY AMONG STARTED SCHOOL EARLY
I GRADUATE SCHOOL AT A SIXTEEN
YEARS OLD AND THEN WENT TO
BRADLEY UNIVERSITY WHERE I WAS
ONE OF ELEVEN BLACKMAIL
FRESHMAN.
OUT OF A.
INCOMING CLASS OF ONE THOUSAND
I WAS THE ONLY BLACK MALE
ENGINEERING MAJOR IN A BRADLEY
WHICH IS PUBLIC IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE PERCENT WHITE SCHOOL
TIME THAT I WENT THERE.
SO BE AND THEN AFTER THAT ARE
GOING TO.
GOING TO WORK FOR ROCKWELL
COLLINS WHO HAS GIVEN ME A
PRETTY UNIQUE EXPERIENCE ON
THIS.
SO IT IS FROM THAT IS FROM THAT
PLACE IN THAT EXPERIENCE WHICH I
SPEAK TO YOU ALL THE DAY.
COME AND AT THE RISK OF
SOUNDING.
PRETENTIOUS YOU KNOW I AM WHAT
YOU ARE TRYING TO CREATE.
I AM AN ENGINEER BECAUSE OF
PROGRAMS THAT WERE PRE A PRE
COLLEGE BECAUSE PROGRAMS I CAN
TELL YOU THE MINUTE BUT I
DECIDED I WANTED TO BE A
MECHANICAL ENGINEER WAS NINTH
GRADE. AND I WANTED ENGINEERING
OPEN HOUSE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
ILLINOIS' AND EXPLAIN ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT YOU NEARING CIVIL
ELECTRICAL MECHANICAL ASSAULT
ROBOTICS OPEN HOUSE LIKE THAT I
WANTED TO DO THAT.
ON IBM ONCE I WAS IN ONE
THOUSAND COLLEGE I GOT WILL
ACTUALLY BEFORE I GOT IN THE
COLLEGE ALMOST PART OF THE
INROADS PROGRAM WHICH.
TALKS WHICH TAUGHT HOME.
WHICH TAUGHT OF PEOPLE FROM
MINORITY BACKGROUNDS BUSINESS
SKILLS YOU KNOW HOW TO HOW TO
ACT HOW TO BEHAVE YOU KNOW
STRATEGIES TO DO IT IS FOR ME
COMING FROM EAST SAINT LOUIS. A
LOT OF THOSE THINGS WERE.
WERE NOT KNOWN TO ME SO TO BE
JUST FRANK HERE A WE ALL KNOW
WHAT THE PROBLEMS ARE WE KNOW
WITH ENCOURAGED BY OUR AND WE
KNOW WHAT EQUITY. WE EQUITY I
DON'T HAVE TO TELL THAT TO YOU
ALL BUT MYSELF BEING AN ENGINEER
I DON'T DEAL WITH THE WORDS I
LIKE IT TO BE I DEAL WITH THE
WATER TO THE. EQUITY IS IT HERE
AND IT'S NOT GONNA BE HERE IN
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS AND WE NEED
TO ACCEPT THAT.
SO IT IS WITH THAT IT IS WITH
THAT ATTITUDE.
LET US SAY WHAT I SEE FROM MINE
IS THAT THERE'S JUST NOT ENOUGH
SUPPORT I'M THANKFUL FOR THIS
BUT ARM I CAN'T PAYMENT
I STILL HAVE A PAYMENT RIGHT
NOW.
BOB I'M WAITING ON A PAYMENT FOR
CLASS THAT I DID AT THE ECO PARK
COMMUNITY CENTER LAST YEAR
THAT'S BEEN WAITING SIX MONTHS.
I'D BUT ARM
IT WILL BE VERY VERY EASY FOR ME
JUST TO GO CHECK MY RESUME OUT
THERE AND GO BUT I BUT I DO THIS
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN IT BECAUSE
IT'S IMPORTANT ME AND ALSO AS AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE. I STAND
ON THE SHOULDERS OF PEOPLE WHO
CAME BEFORE ME HAVE SACRIFICED A
LOT SO I CAN DO THE OPPORTUNITY
OF THINGS THAT THEY HAD NEVER
HAD MIND OF NO CONTINUE DOING
THAT. UNTIL I AM NO LONGER ABLE
TO BUT.
WHEN IT WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO
THE ACTUAL PROGRAMMING AND THE
AND LIKE I SAY WHY I WOULD LOVE
YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE HEARD SOME OF
THE THINGS LIKE OF THE LADY
EARLIER WAS TALKING ABOUT. OWNED
THE KIDS WHO ARE WHO WHO BUILT
OF WHO WHO BUILT ON ACT AND
THINGS LIKE THAT THERE'S ALWAYS
A LOT OF FLASH AND SIZZLE WHEN
IT COMES TO TECH BUT FOR ME I'M
IN THE TREE.
I AM VERY THANKFUL TO THE TO
EFFORTS LIKE THE RAILS PROGRAM
WHICH ALLOWED ME TO DO A TWELVE
WEEK PROGRAMMING CLASS WITH
QUEEN TICKET FOR RISKING THE
COLLABORATIVE. ALTHOUGH BECAUSE
OF SOME OF THEM.
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT WE
WERE UNABLE TO MEET IN TIME I
DON'T THINK THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
AGAIN THIS YEAR BUT STILL THAT
OF THAT GRANT HAS ALLOWED US TO
PUT THAT NETWORKING EQUIPMENT
WERE ACTUALLY CURRENTLY BUILDING
OUT.
SOME SOME NETWORKING
INFRASTRUCTURE CYBERSECURITY IS
ACTUALLY REALLY BIG THING SO I
MEAN I MEAN AT THE END THE DAY
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER WE GET THE
CASH OR NOT I'M GONNA KEEP DOING
THIS FOR AS LONG AS I CAN.
BUT THE THING IS IS THAT.
REALLY TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS I MEAN YOU CAN
LOOK AT JUST THE.
IN THIS ROOM I MEAN AND I THINK
THERE'S A POINT WHERE THE THING
I LIKE ABOUT TEACHING KIDS IS
THAT IS THE TYPE OF THING THAT.
NOBODY REALLY HE DISAGREES WITH
IN THEORY BUT WHEN IT ACTUALLY
COMES DOWN TO WHAT IT COMES DOWN
TO GETTING TO IT WILL BE HARD TO
DO AND AS YOU KNOW I CAN'T PAY
MY RENT RIGHT NOW.
SO.
SO I GUESS THE TAKE AWAY IS IS
THAT NOW THAT ONCE WE. ESTABLISH
THE FACT THAT EQUITY WHILE THAT
IS THE GOLD IS NOT WE'RE GOING
TO GET TO. DEALING WITH THE
WORLD CITY IS TECH DOESN'T
ALWAYS HAVE TO BE EXPERT.
ON THERE ARE A LOT OF OPEN
SOURCE TOOLS OUT THERE THERE ARE
A LOT OF THINGS OUT THERE AND IT
IS FROM THAT. IT IS FROM THAT SO
THAT BACKYARDS WHICH FROM I
TEACH.
A LOT OF THE COMPUTERS ARGUES
THAT PROBABLY HAVE ABOUT EIGHTY
LAPTOPS WHICH WE USED TO GOING
INTO FIVE MOST OF THEM ARE
SECOND HAND SOME OF THEM UP A
LOT OF THEM. ARE PAID OUT OF MY
OWN POCKET SOME OF THEM SOME OF
OUR EQUIPMENT HAS A CAN MEAN
THAT WE HAVE BEEN LUCKY ENOUGH
TO WORK TO BUILD THAT THROUGH
SOME OF THE OF FUNDING THAT
WE'VE GOTTEN. ARM AND SO WE AND
SO IT'S ALWAYS JUST AS ALWAYS
HAS BEEN MY LIFE WITH THE
ATTITUDE THAT GOT ME THROUGH
SCHOOL THAT'S GOT ME THROUGH A
WORK ENVIRONMENT. THE WORLD WHAT
IT IS AND IT'S MY JOB TO DEAL TO
TO DEAL WITH WHAT I'VE GOT TO
THE BEST THAT I CAN WITH.
BUT I'M I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
A SHIFT IN HOW WE DEAL WITH THIS
STUFF BECAUSE HONESTLY WE ALWAYS
WANT TO GET THE CHINESE NEW
COMPUTERS YOU WANT TO GET.
SLAP AND HAVE THE KIDS IN THEIR
BUT A LOT OF TIMES WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT WE'RE LEARNING
HOW WE'RE TEACHING.
A LOT OF TIMES I DO A LOT OF
STUFF BASED OFF WERE DOING A
BASS ELECTRONICS HOME JUST TO
COST WISE I'M IF YOU GET AN OLD
COMPUTER. BUILD OUT KIPPER ABOUT
ANYWHERE BETWEEN THIRTY AND
FORTY FIVE BUCKS PER KID TEACH
BASIC PROGRAMMING ELECTRONICS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE BLOWING OUT RIGHT NOW I
HAVE THAT. RIGHT NOW ACTUALLY
JUST AGAIN THROUGH SOME OF THE
MONEY
I GOT AN ORDER FROM SIERRA
PRODUCED YEAR COLLEGE AND TO
SOME THE STRONG WORK FORCE TO DO
A PILOT PROGRAM WITH THAT.
WITHOUT WHICH INDICATE GAKI TO
EIGHT SCHOOL A WE'VE ALSO DONE
PARTNERSHIPS WE JUST FINISHED A
ON A HACKATHON WITH UBER IN SAN
FRANCISCO WE'VE DONE FIVE PACKET
PARENTS OVER THE LAST A THREE
YEARS PULLING ABOUT A HUNDRED
PLUS KIDS JUST GET JUST ABOUT
EVERYONE. I'M I'M LOOKING TO GO
AHEAD AND.
I'M LOOKING TO GO AHEAD AND.
PRO PARLAY OUR LAST PACMAN THIS
WE CAN WE TOOK FIFTY KIDS MOSTLY
FROM THIS AREA DOWN TO SAN
FRANCISCO TO DO HACKATHON BASED
ON SIX CYBERSECURITY WITH UBER.
I'M LOOKING A ROLL THEM INTO THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO URBAN LEGAL
PROFESSIONALS THEY OF SERVICES
ABLE TWENTY EIGHTH
SO ALL I CAN SAY IS THAT WE ARE
DOING THE WORK BUT WE NEED TO
SUPPORT. ON IT'S ACTUALLY IRONIC
THAT CAN HAPPEN TO BE TALKING
TODAY BECAUSE I JUST ACTUALLY
JUST FOUND OUT ABOUT A TWO HOURS
AGO. A THAT I WAS REJECTED FOR
THE NEW AMERICA.
CALIFORNIA.
OF FELLOW PHILIP PROGRAM WHICH
I PLAN TO SUPPORT MY EFFORTS
THERE BUT YOU KNOW THAT'S YOU
KNOW I'M I'M NOT GONNA CRY
BASSMAN HAVE ACCESS YOU KNOW.
THE THING THAT REALLY STICKS
ABOUT IT WAS THAT IT THAT THE
STATE YOU KNOW WE HAD A SLICK
EIGHT OUT OF APPLE EIGHTY
APPLICATION SO I'M NOT GOING TO
SIT HERE. AND SAY OH I SHOULD'VE
GOTTEN AS CODE OF A PERSON OF
COLOR THIS
BUT THAT'S REALLY WHAT THE BIAS
IS A LOT OF THESE THINGS ARE
HAPPENING.
AND YOU GET INVITED TO THE PARTY
AND YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW THE
RULES
SO A LOT OF THAT IS THIS WITH
ALL OF THE SUPPORTING WITH ALL
THESE REQUIREMENTS ON PLEASE
ARM.
KEEP IN MIND THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
DOING THE WORK A IT GREAT
ACOSTA THEMSELVES BUT AGAIN I
DON'T WANT YOUR PITY I'M NOT
LOOKING FOR THIS I PAY THE PRICE
GLAD I MEAN IT'S A CHOICE THAT I
MAKE.
BUT I JUST WANT TO REMIND ALL OF
YOU
THAT ARM IT. IF IF WHILE THE
IDEAS ALWAYS LIKE THE CHINESE
COMPUTERS AND THAT AND WE DON'T
HAVE TO DO IT THAT WAY. AND IF
ANYBODY'S INTERESTED ABOUT HOW
WE CAN DO IT YOU KNOW GET
SOMETHING DONE WITH THE BUDGETS
THAT WE HAVE. I WOULD VERY MUCH
ENCOURAGE YOU TO TALK TO MY
PARTNER ARE MYSELF AND I'LL SHOW
YOU WITH SOME OF THE STUFF THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING AND THE STORY
GOT NOT REALLY A GOOD NUMBERS
WYOMING NUMBERS.
BUT I'M STORY AND REGION ACROSS
WHEN NUMBERS GUY.
HOME THERE'S A LOT MORE THAT I
COULD SAY ABOUT MY EXPERIENCE
ABOUT SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT I PET BUT IT'S GOING TO BE
RESPECTFUL OF TIME AND I'M
REALLY THANKFUL FOR ALL OF YOU
STILL STICKING AROUND TO HEAR ME
TALK. ON BELIEVE ME ARM I COULD
GO IT LEFT ABOUT ANY OF IT SO
HOME YOU GUYS KNOW GINA YOU KNOW
HOW TO FIND ME AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVE A PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH ALL OF YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
VERY WELL SAID WELL DONE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC.
OKAY BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU WHAT I FIRST WANT TO
THANK OUR PANELISTS FOR BEING
HERE OUT FOR THE FOR THIS
ONGOING CONVERSATION IT'S A
CONVERSATION THAT.
I WAS HAPPY STARTED IN SILICON
VALLEY AND A FEW MONTHS BACK
WITH THAT REALLY HONEST OPEN. OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT DIVERSITY
ATTACK IN AND CONCRETE WAYS WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD HOW WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD TOGETHER SO I APPRECIATE
THE SPIRIT I APPRECIATE THE
FOLLOW UP I THINK TODAY'S.
CONVERSATION CONTINUES TO BUILD
ON WHAT WE'VE STARTED. AND ARM.
SPECIFICALLY APPRECIATE SOME OF
THE THE INSIGHT TODAY I AM AT
GIRLS OF COLOR IN IN IN STEM.
I THINK WHAT.
WE CONTINUE TO ASK OURSELVES AS
LEGISLATORS IS HOW CAN WE BE
PRODUCTIVE HELPFUL PARTNERS IN
ADDRESSING.
I'M EQUITY AND DIVERSITY ATTACK
YOU KNOW OTHER BUDGET PRIORITIES
WHAT WE CAN HELP FIND OUT
INITIATIVES TO HELP BUILD THE
PIPELINE FOR FOR FOR GREATER
DIVERSITY ARE THE LEGISLATION
THAT CAN. REMOVE RESTRICTIONS OR
OPEN UP NEW POSSIBILITIES AND
OPPORTUNITIES
SO I JUST WANT TO ASK OUR OUR.
PANELIST WHAT ARE SOME THINGS
THAT THAT WE CAN DO AS WE
COLLECTIVELY HOLD UP THIS ISSUE
AND TRY TO ADDRESS IT TOGETHER
WHAT CAN OUR ROLE BE WHAT CAN
WORK BUT PARK WE DO IN SOLVING
THIS ISSUE THAT WE ALL CARE
ABOUT DEEPLY. AND AND AND DOM
ONE RESOLVE.
BUT AS THE BOOK FROM THE K.
TWELVE PERSPECTIVE ARM YOU KNOW
THERE IS THIS NEW LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA SO THAT A LOT OF
THE FUNDING IS SORT OF
DIVERSIFIED AND LOCALIZING YOU
CAN CHOOSE HOW TO SPEND IT BUT.
I YOU KNOW I THINK IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT TO KIND OF SEE THE
NUMBERS LIKE WE HAVE BEEN AP AND
HONORS COURSES BY ETHNICITY BY
GENDER.
WITH REGARD TO THE COURSE WORK
IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS RIGHT AND
WHAT'S NEEDED AND DOOR TO
ENCOURAGE MORE GIRLS INSTANCE OF
COLOR AND. YOU KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW I'M NOT FOR BIG MANDATES ON
ON SCHOOLS BUT SHINING THE LIGHT
AND SHOWCASING SIR WHAT ARE THE
NUMBERS AND AND MAKING SURE THAT
THE. TEACHERS AND SCHOOLS LOOK
AT THEIR NUMBERS AND AND SEE
THAT THAT YOU'RE NOT JUST
GRADUATING KIDS BUT WHEN YOU
GRADUATING OF THEM AND HOW ARE
YOU PASSING THEM THROUGH AND
WHOSE PROVIDED. YOU KNOW
TUTORING ASSISTANCE ON
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT REALLY
IMPORTANT ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT WE OF PARTNER WITH THE.
STEMS OPPOSE THE STEAM SUPPOSE
IT LAST FIVE YEARS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA'S FOR DEDICATED OF
EDUCATION FOR A FOUNDATION IS.
OF BECAUSE TEACHERS DIDN'T KNOW
HOW TO OF YOU KNOW. STREAMLINED
ARTICULATE STEM EDUCATOR STEAM
EDUCATION IN THE COURSE WORK AND
SO WE HAD A CONFERENCE FOR
TEACHERS BY TEACHERS AND WE HAVE
FIVE THOUSAND. OF OUR EDUCATORS
COMEY THOSE CONFERENCES ONCE A
YEAR WHICH HAS BEEN A GREAT HELP
SO SUPPORT DEFINITELY IMPRESSION
OF DEVELOPER FOR UNCONSCIOUS
BIAS A BUT ALSO HOW TO MARKET
HOW TO PROVIDE THE ASSISTANCE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. OF BECAUSE
THAT'S YOU HAVE A CAPTIVE
AUDIENCE OF A IT'S A PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM AND YOU'LL SEE THE
THREE TO ONE TWO TO ONE RATIO OF
GIRLS TO BOYS IN THIS. VERY SAME
OF SITE I COMPLETELY CAN
CURRENTLY
BE DIE I'M I THINK AYE AYE THE
WAY THAT THAT WE THINK ABOUT
THIS IS SORT OF IN FOUR
CATEGORIES. READ THE FIRST IS
DID YOU KNOW AND I THINK THIS
SORT OF GETS TO YOUR FOR YOUR
PEACE OF OF EDUCATION.
WHAT IS CURRENTLY BEING DONE
WHAT IS IT WILL OCCUR WHAT OUR
CURRENT PRACTICES WATER BEST
PRACTICES?
LEARNING FROM THOSE.
BUT BUT IT IS IN THAT CATEGORY
OF DID YOU KNOW RIGHT.
.
AND THE ACTING TALENT SEARCH
RIGHT I THINK WE TALKED ABOUT
RECRUITING AND RETENTION.
POLICYMAKERS WITH YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WORKING TOGETHER.
WITH THE COMEDIAN WITH THE
INDUSTRY ON TO PROVIDE EXPOSURE.
SO THAT SORT OF JUST YOU KNOW
WHAT TALENTS OUT THERE WHAT
TALENT CAN WE EXPOSE THESE
OPPORTUNITIES TO.
BUT WORKING TOGETHER IN
PARTNERSHIP THEIR.
BUILDING THE BATCH RIGHT THIS
IS SORT OF THIS THIS
CONVERSATION OF THE PIPELINE
THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT YOU KNOW
TECH THAT WAS A CO SPONSOR OF
THAT LEGISLATION AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY NINE PASSING TWENTY
SIXTEEN. AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY
WOMAN BO DNIA.
WHICH CREATES A COMPUTER
SCIENCE STRATEGIC ADVISORY BOARD
THAT PROCESS IS CURRENTLY UNDER
WAY AND WE HAVE ONE YEAR TO
IDENTIFY WHERE THE GAPS ARE
WHAT'S CURRENTLY BEING DONE IN
THE AREA OF THE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES.
AND DIVERSITY EXPOSURE TO
COMPUTER SCIENCE SO THAT'S AN
EXAMPLE BUT SORT OF THAT PROCESS
AND THAT GETS TO I'M CREATING
DIVERSITY AND COMMUNITIES.
TEACHER TRAINING RESOURCES
CURRICULUM ENHANCEMENT.
INCREASE THINKING SOFT SKILLS
THE LIST GOES ON AND THE FOURTH
PIECE OF THAT.
IS DIVERSIFICATION IN THE
SUPPLY CHAIN SO.
I KNOW THAT VERIZON HAD ALLUDED
TO THIS AND I KNOW A NUMBER OF
OUR MEMBER COMPANIES ALSO LOOK
AT NOT ONLY THEIR OWN INTERNAL
BUSINESSES BUT HOW ARE THEY
PARTNERING.
ALONG THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND WHAT
ARE THEIR THAT BEING THE SUPPLY
CHAIN FOLKS BEST PRACTICES
AROUND DIVERSE CITY.
SO THESE ARE SORT OF THE FOUR SO
IF YOU LIVE IN AN AREA IN
WHICH YOUR HOUSE IS WORTH MORE
MONEY YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A
BETTER A BIGGER FLOW OF FUNDS
GOING INTO YOUR SCHOOLS. AND
THAT NOT ALSO LEADS INTO THE
FAMILY DEMOGRAPHICS AS FAR AS
HOW ACTIVE THEY ARE BECAUSE WE
HAVE A DIFFERENT COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT DYNAMIC IN THE
HOUSEHOLD.
SO LOOKING INTO I'M UNDERSERVED
AT COMMUNITIES AND ADDING THAT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR NOT ONLY
EDUCATION TO THE STUDENTS BUT
EDUCATION IN THE COMMUNITY OF
HOW IMPORTANT STEM AND
TECHNOLOGY IS. AMOUNTS WERE
MOVING INTO AN AUTONOMOUS WORLD
OUR WHOLE WORKFORCE IS GOING TO
CHANGE DRAMATICALLY I MEAN AND
IF I'M WE'RE NOT READY FOR IT.
WE'RE PUSHING AUTONOMOUS CARS
WERE WERE PUSHING AUTONOMOUS
TRANSPORTATION HERE IN THE CITY
WHAT HAPPENS TO THOSE BLUE
COLLAR WORKERS. EVERYTHING FROM
THE ACTUAL DRIVER TO THE PERSON
WHO ACTUALLY FIXES THE TIRES ALL
THE WAY DOWN TO EVEN THE
INSURANCE AGENT EVERYTHING'S
GOING TO CHANGE DRASTICALLY AND
WE ARE NOT READY WE WORK WE ARE
READY NOW FOR THE WORK FORCE
THAT WE HAVE. WERE DEATHLY NOT
GOING TO BE READY IN FIVE TO TEN
YEARS SO FUNDING FOR PUTTING
FUNDING INTO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES SO WE CANNOT ONLY
EDUCATE. THE CHILDREN BUT ALSO
THE COMMUNITIES ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF IT AND WHAT'S
COMING TO CHANGE I'VE I FIND
VERY VITAL AND AND SOMETHING
THAT EXTREME PORTENTS RIGHT NOW.
APPRECIATE ALL THE RESPONSES I
JUST WANNA SAY THAT AS AS CHAIR
OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I'VE BEEN.
REALLY EXCITED TO BE PART
CONVERSATION WITH YOU AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. OUR THE HONESTY
AND OPENNESS IN THE AND THE
WILLINGNESS TO WORK TOGETHER IN
THE FOR TO OUR ONGOING WORK
TOGETHER THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
OKAY WELL THEN I WILL CLOSE THIS
UP IN.
AS WAS A THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY
THAT CAME TODAY APOLOGIZES A FEW
MINUTES LATER IT WAS INCREDIBLE
CONVERSATION IT AND I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THE. THE ETHNIC
MINORITY.
PART OF THIS BUT WHAT I CAN'T
SPEAK TO AS A FATHER OF TWO
LITTLE GIRLS.
THAT ARE SIX I'M SORRY HER
BIRTHDAY'S TODAY. SO THEY ARE
NINE AND EIGHT TODAY.
AND SO IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO ME AS MY DAUGHTERS
GROW UP THAT EVERY OPPORTUNITY
THAT THEY WANT TO.
DO WHEN LIFE IS AFFORDED TO THEM
AND WHEN YOU DOUBLE THAT WITH
THAT. UNETHICAL MINORITY ASPECT
TO THIS AND IT MAKES IT EVEN
HARDER IS SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE.
AND SO AS A COMMITTEE WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY.
CHALLENGED
TO FIXING THIS PROBLEM AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO FIND A SOLUTION
SO THANK YOU THERE'S NO OTHER
COMMENTS WE'LL CLOSE THIS
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU